hey guys pete here
we're here to talk about the penultimate
episode of better call saul
there's only one more left and this one
set things up in a way that was
absolutely satisfying as far as i was
concerned um it's just me and gil today
i invited him here so we can talk about
the episode
talk about what we think is going on
with each of the characters they sort of
got everything down to just two of them
now um which is which is pretty insane
when you think about how big this
universe is and how many characters
we've met throughout those series
there's only really that those two to
think about
and um you know we're going to do that
we're going to talk to about that today
we're going to
answer your questions
i i think um
you know usually i'll throw it out to
you and you'll you'll do your what you
thought of the episode overall and i
think since it's just me and you today
why don't we
i wanted to talk about kim a little bit
kim in florida especially
before we get into answering the
questions and
we were talking a little bit
behind the scenes before we started and
i think
you know the first time i watched this i
was sort of like what's going on with
kim
uh you know she's not in hiding
obviously saul
practiced law he you know he he was a
public figure
uh there was no reason to think that the
police might come after her there may
have been a little bit of the idea that
cartel could be you know
there but not really you know it for the
most part
she was living in this completely kind
of opposite way
and it's funny because we have you know
gene in the cold and her and the hot
down in florida
so it's just like night and day and he's
he's
jumping into this idea of like
being saul to to cope with with the loss
and and all the other stuff that
happened
and she is
just living a normal life and and it was
really kind of off-putting because if
she's not if she's not hiding then then
why is she acting like this is she
punishing is she punishing herself is
she afraid that of what she might do
she's not really helping anybody she's
not really doing anything she's just
sort of
existing and um
it was it was really it really took some
time to digest so so why don't you
introduce yourself tell us what you
thought about the episode and let's talk
a little bit about kim in florida before
we get into all the questions
sounds great uh first off pete thank you
for having me on again and for those of
you who don't know me i'm gil i am from
the youtube channel one take where we
talk about better call saul and a bunch
of other stuff and you may also know me
from the podcast sawcast where we talk
about better call saul every week at
least until next week and i still can't
believe there's only one episode left
i absolutely loved last night's episode
it's another one that i would call a
masterpiece and i think it works so well
because it builds on
what we've been watching over the last
seven years
it was a very suspenseful episode to me
even though there wasn't a lot of
violence in it there were of course a
couple moments in the episode that
hinted at a little bit of potential
violence but for me the suspense came
from
better call saul's strongest trait which
is it's focused on character
and we have been watching jimmy and kim
both deal with trauma in their lives and
both have to some extent
uh kind of shove that stuff down inside
of themselves especially jimmy so it
feels like they both have trauma
guilt and a lot of difficult things in
their lives that are kind of trapped
behind these floodgates holding those
emotions back and the suspense for me is
waiting for those floodgates to crack
open when i was watching kim this
episode i kept waiting for something to
make her think of saul
something to make her think of howard
we'll of course get into more detail
what is kim doing there in florida but i
think broadly she has erased her
previous life and i was afraid for the
moment where that previous life might
come back to haunt her and when it does
we kind of see that damn break and we
see those emotions come out so i found
the episode very suspenseful just
waiting for these characters to deal
with their past traumas we saw a lot of
it from kim this episode
and i am still
uh
i'm still afraid of what's going to
happen
when jimmy possibly faces a similar
situation where he maybe finally faces
up to some of the trauma in his past
uh and i'll just add the black and white
has been such an interesting choice from
the beginning but this episode is where
i really saw how it helps the show
a lot of time has passed from the events
that we watched in this series you know
about six years right
and you definitely feel the passage of
time but i think you feel it a little
bit more because of the black and white
it makes everything we're seeing here
feel so separate and so distant from
those past events
so when these things
when it kim gets the call from jimmy and
it's that past coming back to haunt her
it truly feels like ancient history you
know somebody on my live stream last
night mentioned they can't believe
that nacho died in episode three this
season it feels like that was two or
three seasons ago
so i think these characters feel a lot
of distance from these past events and
thanks to the black and white we do too
and
and when those past events come back
come knocking on their doors
um it feels like
it feels like an invasion into this
black and white space for us
and i think that gets us to feel a bit
of what they feel where it feels like an
invasion into kind of this epilogue to
the exciting part of their lives
so very suspenseful episode for me very
tragic very emotional episode
um and and i loved it
yeah
you were talking a little bit about
invasion and that's what i was thinking
about as far as
you know kim's little life there and
what she build up and you know jimmy
waited a long time you know we saw that
whenever they did the the signing of the
divorce papers that he wasn't ready to
look at that he wasn't ready to you know
face what was really happening
and so we see him in this in this
black and white life like you're
pointing out there and
you know that's what it felt like is
that he you know he was he was pushing
his way in there and he knew it you know
what i mean like there's a part of him
that knew that so when he doesn't get a
reaction
he's the one that actually escalates
everything and and freaks out and that
becomes the catalyst for what she
decides to do
but i but i agree 100 that that is
something that's totally different in in
black and white and it's also because
it's you know that it has that feel that
stark feeling of like there's not that
many choices you know there's not that
much
stimulation nothing else you know like
you think about i looked at the pictures
the behind the scenes pictures that they
put out and you know seeing kim in with
with the the new hairstyle and the new
the new look seeing that in color and
seeing that in florida it would have
played totally differently if it wasn't
in black and white you know what i mean
the it that it seemed
there's nothing
realistically there's nothing wrong with
the life she's leaving you know we know
it's different than how we met her so it
feels off to us
but it's a normal life but you put that
in black and white you put that in
you know outside of albuquerque you know
outside of omaha
and it really does make a difference and
you know one of the things you're
talking about suspense and i and i think
what really dawned on me towards the end
of this episode was
these characters are doing exactly what
they're supposed to be doing you know
what makes sense for what we've been
told about them what we've watched for
all these seasons
and yet we've been watching we've been
following along we've been rooting for
different ones at different times and
you know we set up this expectation
that isn't really in line with what
should or shouldn't happen you know what
i mean
and so
you know by the end i'm thinking you
know okay well that kind of changes
everything
but it but it doesn't you know because
that they set that up so well that it's
just the characters being what they are
and our expectations you know sort of
having to readjust to be like okay yeah
this is where we're at right now jimmy
has a a phone cord wrapped around his
head like your hands like garat and he's
he could
possibly kill legendary actress uh
you know
carol burnett mm-hmm
so it's a it was it's it's an amazing
thing that they're doing here yeah i'm
really glad that we're we're getting to
watch it live yeah i think about it i
and many people have thrown the word
redemption around a lot wanting to see
jimmy redeem himself wanting to see him
get away from his bad habits the way
that he deals with trauma basically by
not dealing with it and the question is
what will teach him the lesson to stop
dealing with the problems in his life by
becoming saul goodman
shutting down his feelings and
essentially becoming the socio sociopath
that can say to his now ex-wife you know
have a good life and you know sayonara
we want to see that but what does it
take to shake somebody out of that and
apparently
working with walter white heisenberg
meth kingpin
and losing everything isn't enough to
shake him out of that um so what's it
gonna take
and is there anything that can save him
at this point and just to your point
we we shouldn't have expected him to to
learn anything i mean time and time
again we've seen him fall into this
pattern and so he's just continuing to
fall into this pattern but the magic
trick of the show is that they still get
us to hope when he found out that this
guy has cancer i'm sitting there saying
okay of course he's going to walk away
now he's not going to take advantage of
this guy
but but of course he does
right so this is exactly what you said
um the show is getting us to watch with
suspense hope for a certain outcome and
then the actual outcome occurs and you
say well i mean it makes total sense
that it went that way
yeah and that's why i found the whole
thing with kim fascinating because you
know like i mentioned she's not hiding
and you know there's that idea of
is she punishing herself like in the
same way that jimmy throws himself into
these scams to just sort of distract is
she trying to somehow
not necessarily redeem herself but you
know take on that responsibility of the
cause of the harm that she's caused
and you know it it's hard to say exactly
like a lot of this stuff that i'm
thinking about now like i was thinking
right before we started there's a lot
i'm still kind of processing about this
and it's not necessarily because it was
somehow
you know unclear
it's just that so many things are are
still
up in the air as far as what's going to
happen next next week and and it comes
down to what you're saying there like is
there a thing that that can
shift jimmy and
you know we did see that crack of light
at the end of the episode whenever he he
doesn't kill marion you know or he
doesn't stop her from calling you know
using the life alert he he certainly
could have and you know didn't have to
be as as violent or as as extreme as him
killing her but he you know he he could
have stopped that whole thing from
happening and we saw you know i think
jimmy mcgill i think we saw jimmy there
and you know it was a is a big it's a he
covered a lot of distance internally
from where he was was in the last two
episodes to get to that place but
what i don't even know what that means
you know like you say redemption and
it's sort of like what would that even
look like or
maybe the best that we can hope for is
just kind of relief because it looks
absolutely painful the way that he's
living his life you know what i mean
he he's not just making bad decisions
and causing harm for other people but
he's it's a torturous existence don't
you think oh yeah yeah for sure and
i think for kim too uh i think there's
nothing and vince gilligan said this in
a sort of defensive way on the insider
podcast there's nothing intrinsically
wrong with the life that kim is living
you know i think it's easy on these
shows we identify with these people that
have these exciting very unusual lives
when you compare that to the normies in
the show like frank chomping down on his
cinnamon rolls it's easy to look at them
and say wow look at those boring
just torturous
repetitive lives they're leading
but i think that's because we're seeing
it through these characters eyes
and
for kim
this is a torturous existence for her
because like you pointed out earlier kim
has always been the self-assured person
who makes choices the old kim when she
was asked strawberry or vanilla she
would have had an answer and would have
had a great reason and a very convincing
reason for which flavor she chose but
she is not allowing herself to make
choices
she has this great gift where she can
defend people who need to help and
nobody else has given them that help and
she's depriving herself in the world
of that talent so
this world is a torturous one for her i
mean that's why the black and white
works for us that's why the focus on the
mundane um works really well i love that
moment where that one character is
saying you know i was gonna try almond
butter today instead of peanut and then
it just cuts off and they're focusing on
those mundane details because
that's the torture of being of being kim
right now she's stuck in this boring
existence where she doesn't get to be
who she wants to be
yeah the miracle whip was the one that
really hit me when i watched it the
first time it's like that you know
not to put down miracle whip or anything
like that i mean money was tight when i
was growing up and we definitely had it
around our household and stuff but it's
not a it's not a it's not a just a
there's there's a big difference in
those two two things you know i mean and
um
whenever she she didn't even really
consider
you know she just sort of deferred to
the to the to her new boyfriend
and just sort of uh
waited to see if it was okay or not from
him
you know i was seriously like is you
know what's going on with this character
right and then i was in that same part
where they were talking about the almond
butter you know she eventually addresses
it as she's eating it's like okay she
still has
there's still something in there you
know i mean she still understands you
know she's still experiencing life it's
just that she's depriving herself of
that
idea of making choices she doesn't want
to make the wrong choices so she just
defers the whole thing and it's exactly
opposite to the person that we've met
and what's made her a dynamic and
lovable character right and i think why
is she doing this you know you've
mentioned a couple of possibilities and
i think
probably they're both in the mix and i
think if you were to take kim and ask
her why are you doing this i don't know
that she would be totally clear in her
mind so probably the answer is is mixed
but you mentioned the possibility that
she's afraid of making choices because
the last time she did that it got
someone killed
and and the other possibility as is that
she's punishing herself she is it's kind
of it's it's luke skywalker and the last
jedi this is a self-imposed exile and
i'll say that's probably the reasoning
that most resonates with me this does
feel like she is punishing herself
uh she is going by the name kim wexler
she is not on the run
i think anybody outside law enforcement
that would want some kind of wretch not
even retribution i guess but want to
take her out because she knows too much
all those people are gone at this point
so she's not on the run this is a
self-imposed exile i think she feels
guilty
and
she doesn't know how to rid herself of
that guilt
so the best she can do is basically pay
penance she punishes herself
by taking away her ability to practice
law by taking her away her ability to
make any choices in her life she's she
stripped herself of everything that
makes her the kim wexler kim wexler that
we knew and loved
um so so i i guess i think there's a mix
of things going on here but the one that
most resonates with me
is is sort of punishing herself to try
and rid herself of that guilt
yeah and um
you know we got to jump into some
questions now but we'll come back around
to this as it comes up because i you
know i'm realizing it you know as we're
talking that there's i'm still i'm still
kind of processing the situation you
know
it's it's it's it's complicated and it's
and it's fabulous and i'm sure we're
going to have a lot of questions as we
go through so
definitely
revisit it um all right john baptist
thank you for the five dollars what a
sad episode there is no justification
ever for divorce kim should
kim never should have left jimmy i felt
sick seeing her live another life well
uh you know i can't i necessarily agree
with what you you're you're saying there
but i mean you know that's that is a
point of view
uh
it was you know i can agree that it was
it was sad to see her living a different
life
i i would say that
you know the decisions she made and the
way that it played out it all made sense
to me it all seemed true to the
character and the story they were
telling
so you know i don't know that
you know i i wouldn't look at it through
this lens so i i can't really you know
like there's not really much more i can
say but except to say that you know for
me at least it it it rang true to what
the characters you know what was set up
for the characters
roger rubio thank you for the five
dollars now that we've seen the two
episodes that followed
do you view the episode nippy
differently now
what is your favorite three episode
stretch of bcs so that's a difficult
question that i'll try to think about in
the back of my mind
for a simpler question what do i think
about nippy
i mean i kind of like nippy in the first
place you know i didn't really i didn't
have a a bad reaction to it um
it wasn't as good as the one before it
and it's not as good as as 612 but
it made sense i thought to um
give you know
kind of kind of have a a little bit of
room to breathe after the intense
you know talking about three episode
stretches
seven
eight and nine
is is a contender for that and it was a
pretty intense stretch so so nippy was a
good chance to
kind of see a little bit of jimmy
before they took this hard turn into him
being saul again
um did did you gail did you you
thought nippy was fine when it came out
right yeah yeah i like nippy and i was
pretty happy with the placement of of
nippy um it was it was kind of a left
turn that i think surprised pretty much
all of us because we had that flash
forward to saul goodman and then all of
a sudden we cut through gene takavik
but i thought the placement of it worked
really well because i i think that these
stories generally work best when we're
feeling at least a piece of what the
characters are feeling and in nippy what
gene was feeling is the excitement of
rediscovering the saul goodman part of
himself
and in this stretch of episodes where it
was very dark dire tragic
episodes very few jimmy slip and jimmy
saw goodman antics in those episodes so
after that stretch to get this nippy
episode
we felt some of that relief of getting
to just see saul goodman having fun
again
if we went into the breaking bad
timeline saw saul goodman antics and
then had nippy it would have felt like
oh this is more of the same
so for me the placement of the episode
actually worked really well the tone of
it giving us like you said a chance to
breathe before things get intense again
i think works really well
and i think i will remember nippy fondly
it's kind of that one last
season one esque
fun episode
before we get into the finale of better
call saul
yeah i i agree with that i mean that's
what i that's what i was left with after
the fact it might not have been what i
wanted and the moment because like you
said we had that flash forward so my
expectations were elsewhere but it was
it felt really good to have one more of
those season one style episodes and and
just let them do that and
it it was you know there was some fun
moments it ended up being you know
kind of a harbinger of what there was
become because and that was sort of
going through my head the whole time
because i'm thinking about them
being
addicts now and about how he's you know
relapsing and how that doesn't seem like
a good thing
good things are going to come out of
that in the for the future but
you know it was you know i agree with
everything that you say there do you
have a three
and three episode stretch is kind of
hard i mean i think eight nine and ten
of season five
beyond that it's hard for me to like
really pin down three episodes in a row
to answer this question
yeah yeah i agree with you it's it's
almost like i i really think of all the
episodes as part of one big story i mean
they flow together so seamlessly
uh the gene episodes here feel like
their own individual unit so i think
when i reflect back on the show
that's the part i'm gonna remember if
i'm trying to pick out you know three or
four episodes that go together um but
yeah you mentioned the end of season
five those kind of flowed together
pretty well too
because you remember uh bagman leading
right into bad choice road uh that very
intense scene of lala walking into their
condo for the first time um so that's
definitely a contender
but i feel like i need to go back and
rewatch the first three episodes of this
season
because i said it already earlier but
nacho feels like ancient history at this
point and i remember thinking that
episode was it was incredible
um it was the tone of that episode the
visual that i think will be a landmark
for the series in my brain for years to
come
but nachos flower with the storm in the
background and the rain
so i think i'll have to answer this
question after i've done another full
series re-watch so i'll defer for now
yeah i meant to loop back to that too
because
you mentioned getting the comment about
that being in this season i i saw a
couple like that too and
when i was thinking about it i was like
lalo lalo's death was just a few
episodes ago
memory and that even seems like a
distant memory now like and that is
really how effective it has been the way
that they they jump forward in these
last episodes it's like we're in a whole
different season yeah it really feels
that way
all right mike t i missed yours earlier
sorry about that thank you for the five
if kim doesn't break up with jimmy would
he still become the saul from breaking
bad
i mean this is a question that we can't
really answer
and you know in my opinion anyways um
you know i i think that
you know it it depends on how you play
it out you know like i think she was
right in her decision to to leave
because that they would they would
escalate and more bad things would
happen like even if howard didn't die
or she didn't leave something bad would
eventually happen
based on what they were doing and you
know that's what she's trying to avoid
that's what she's trying to hide out
from is to not be that person anymore
does he you know saul is a coping
mechanism so if if if they were if
something bad was always going to happen
and they were always going to break up
as a result
then i think he always becomes saul you
know and there's
i mean it's just i i just don't think
it's something that you can really
answer in a straightforward way yeah i
think for for this what if to occur
either jimmy or kim would have to
fundamentally be different people
because to your point i think something
like what happened to howard is
inevitable because their schemes would
have continued to escalate
until something stopped it and that
something is tragedy that causes kim to
walk away so the only way maybe she
wouldn't break up with saul is if she
already had an experience like this in
the past that taught her hey i shouldn't
scam people because it can go horribly
wrong but in that case she wouldn't have
been with jimmy to begin with
so it's sort of you can't really play
out the what if because these two
characters had to be who they are for
them to be together and then this
conclusion is essentially inevitable
yeah i thought about that a lot with
walter too you know people were saying
well what if he didn't you know what if
if jimmy didn't go after him didn't walk
into that school
i mean walter is a force of nature as
far as i'm concerned so it you know he
some he may have just died he may have
just uh you know
gotten killed earlier or something you
know i mean but
i feel like mayhem was still going to to
come out of that situation one way or
the other you know there's not really a
world where he gets that 770 737
thousand dollars that he thought he
needed and then stops i mean that's not
the nature of it
of what they're doing and and you know
and i think about their scamming and
that escalation like the sort of
progression behind it like they can't go
back and
scam free drinks and get the same thrill
after what they
pulled off with howard if it goes as as
it was planned if he doesn't die at the
end you know they they sort of have to
raise the anterior you know the stakes
each time and
and yeah you know we're pretty much in
agreement here that that will lead to
disaster in one way or the other
isaac drum thank you for the 20 that is
very generous
he's he's symbolism of saul being buried
in desert and breaking bad timeline the
teaser showing a steam in desert
and the teaser of him ripping down
wanted poster leads me to believe he is
headed to albuquerque for his date with
destiny
yeah um
that that has been my my thought was
that he would turn himself in um
seeing kim go back to albuquerque i'm
not really sure if that if that
that changes anything um
it was interesting that she went there
because it felt like it was a kind of a
goodbye to the place but you know it
could just be her goodbye to the place
um
there might be more to see there
uh the the teaser of the esteem
that seems like it's it's it's a ghost
of you know the memory like the ghost of
of what happened before
i'm not sure if there is a
literal purpose to showing that or if
it's just to to kind of evoke those
feelings of
you know who this was the journey that
he went on you know with that car it was
so important in the early part and it
ended up out there
uh decaying in the desert um
what do you think uh gail
yeah i think
they've definitely been playing with a
lot of finale tropes and call backs it's
almost like each episode in the final
stretch here have had callbacks to where
this all started um hey there's a new
trash can in the hhm lobby
uh or showtime folks
or last episode gene doing the uh trying
to get the phone to ring you know with
his mind or
conjure some voicemails or on his
answering machine
and definitely what you expect from a
finale is let's go back to where it all
started so it feels appropriate that
jimmy would head back to albuquerque and
definitely breaking bad and better call
saul both like to play with the kind of
hands of fate
howard and lalo
walking into his apartment at the same
time
so with kim in albuquerque
and
this show feeling like a tragic love
story
it just feels like we need
jimmy and kim to see each other one more
time she's an albuquerque now if we're
gonna go back to where it all started
jimmy heads back to albuquerque maybe
even bumps into kim because they both go
to the same place at the same time
i'll i'd say it it feels right to me it
feels appropriate but this show
definitely likes to surprise us so
gotta wait and see
yeah that's interesting you know when i
watched the episode
my initial take was that her story was
complete like not that she wouldn't come
back necessarily but
kind of from her her perspective it was
you know and
then
the bigger thing was that this is now
about jimmy's desperation to get back
together or at least see her again you
know we that they made that pretty clear
in the way that they they paralleled
each other and they showed how you know
what she was doing was different than
what he was doing
and at the bottom of it all
we know he's motivated by by that that
pain and
and and he really went off the rails
after that call and the way that that
played out
and um
you know i i think
there's a question of
what what that feeling does to him and
how he'll react now that he's on the run
because the scam is over
he can't just go back and
and and and do pull some scams uh with
jeff to to kind of kill the pain to kind
of medicate or whatever you know you
want to call what he's doing
so you know i i
i took her being in the shuttle at the
end where she breaks down and cries i
took that as her going back to florida
um
but i mean i i do
you know i i do think that there's
potential
to see them interact there once again
like i i don't know it seems more likely
than her than him going to florida i
think i mean he does know where she's at
right he could go but you know he's on
the run
so he sort of almost has to go back to
where
you know where he would where his story
would end rather than
picking up new destinations as a wanted
man that makes sense right
yeah no no i would agree with that uh it
kind of feels like the walls have closed
in at this point and if he realizes he
can only
run for a little bit longer he only gets
to go one more place
where would he choose to go
and regarding kim i mean one of the
brilliant things the show is doing right
now is it's getting to a few points
where
you could end and it could be a
inappropriate ending and i would say you
could end the kim's story right now it
just depends on
what peter gould and the rest of the
writers want to say about the kim
character and what they want to say
in in the subtext in the meaning of the
show do they want to say that she is
doomed
she is doomed to carry this guilt
and live in her self-imposed exile and
there is no way to get past it
at least for her because that is what i
would take away if we didn't see her
again and that's totally appropriate and
i wouldn't argue with it
um but i think it's just up to them and
you know how do they want to wrap it up
i would not find it unsatisfying at this
point if we didn't see her again but i
might be disappointed
yeah um
i'm going to come back to that in a
second because there's uh
there's something else that that i
wanted to pull on there but um i want to
knock out a couple of these questions
big ral thank you for the five well have
we we have seen walt and jesse together
and jesse alone
we are due for a walt solo
any ideas um
i'm thinking another flashback obviously
into the breaking bad timeline but i
don't really
have a great idea of
you know
where that could be there was a lot of
talk about it being around the time of
the ricin cigarette and and uh you know
that sort of
you know the the darkest
depths of of what
saul goodman was involved with um
we kind of get this question every
every week and i kind of think that i'm
gonna i'm gonna figure it out by the
next time we come on and it and there's
just so many options you know
like i would have never
i would have never guessed that
kim running into jesse outside was how
how he was going to show up solo you
know and in a way
you couldn't have because i mean i know
there was a photo of it out there and a
lot of people
knew it and based their theories off
that
throughout the season or whatever but
you know the
the the writers even said that they this
was one that was that was pretty much
they just did it because they wanted to
do it not because there was a good
reason for it
the walter thing could be the same or it
could be a really essential thing but i
guess it always comes back to
it always comes back down to me of it
being about
whose soul is what saul's thinking about
and especially now what he's going to be
thinking about while he's
running for his life and and just trying
to make a decision if he wants to to
change his path if he wants to try to
make up for for something or if he wants
to go down in uh blaze of glory
yeah i think the uh
the the jesse
kim conversation is a nice poetry to
that in the sense that
we're seeing her as she is kind of
leaving the grinder of the game it
destroyed her life
and she's meeting jesse right before he
goes into the game
uh so
those two characters are similar in that
way that they both passed through not
unscathed unscathed but they got through
the other side of it intent on not
making the same mistakes again
um so if i think about walt i mean the
parallel to him is saul so i guess i'd
say my prediction is that the
interaction will be between walt and
saul it's not going to be you know with
kim or another side character
and the one place i can think of
is when they were both in the
disappearers basement i know we already
saw them interact but i can't recall if
we saw the entirety of their time
together i wonder if there was a lull
there or maybe they had a conversation
where viewed in this context it could
kind of feel like the two of them
talking and having a meaningful
conversation where the subtext is almost
both of them
reflecting on their journeys and
reflecting on the choices they're about
to make which is uh
in walt's case kind of going out in a
blaze of glory and it seems like gene
may be similar
um so so i guess my my vague prediction
is that it's it's saul and walt and it
will be a conversation that somehow
works as the two of them reflecting on
their journeys in a meaningful way as we
go into the finish line
yeah that's something that i had thought
about in the past would be a good place
to maybe to to maybe fill in some blanks
because they were there for at least 24
hours together in that basement and we
only saw a brief conversation
and and it's one of those times where
you actually could say that you see
jimmy instead of saul you know what i
mean like the the advice that he's
giving him
about turning himself in and all of that
that sounds a lot more like the jimmy
character than the saul character
even though you know the jimmy character
didn't really exist whenever they wrote
that
one thing about that is that we'll have
to we'll have to um we'll have to live
with bald cap discourse again if they if
they do that yeah no ski cap this time
yeah because there's no beanie there's
no beanie assistant in in that uh
basement at all like that doesn't even
make sense
i it's one of the things like after it
it still blows my mind anytime anyone
mentions el camino in anything
it's one of the first things you see is
about how people were just just so so
distraught about him wearing a bald cap
yeah that's something i i recently
admitted that to be completely honest
when i look at it
i just don't see the bald gap
but i know it's one of those subjective
things when you have a deep fake
character for example and some of the
star wars properties some people say hey
it looks fine to me and then for me it's
super off-putting this is similar i look
at the bald cap i look at a side by side
picture and i'm like i don't know
i don't know it looks fine to me so so
i'm not worried about it at least
yeah that's true because you know like
it's not something that ever really i i
i guess i noticed it but it never
distracted me from what the the actor
was doing right what the story was doing
what the character was was was showing
so
uh you know i i guess that's true you
know so for other people it may be super
uh you know super
obvious and and distracting i you know
there's other things if i really think
about it that that probably you know
stand out to me that might not to other
people but
it's just it's just one of those things
every time i see anyone bring up el
camino i was like oh well now we got to
read a bunch of bunch of comments about
the bald cap and
you know instead of like what the person
is actually talking about
uh
do you have a a pronunciation of this
name i see it every week and i
appreciate the uh
the super chats but i have a real hard
time
dang one of my favorite parts of doing
this is seeing you attempt to pronounce
uh some of these names so i kind of
don't want to jump in
yeah
slant
math that's kind of what i would have
said i think
yeah
i'm really sorry i mean i i don't it's
not i'm not making light of of the the
name that you have here i just i really
it
it it confuses my brain when i try to
say the words
thank you for the 699
canadian do you think gene would have
carried out his threat on marion if she
hadn't reminded him of miss landry
or
was he bluffing the whole time
i'm not sure i think this is a case of
he didn't know what he was this is a
heat of the moment situation
there's a possibility that he might have
been scared about what he was doing but
at the same time whenever you're in a
situation like that
he you know he he should be thinking
about that as a matter of survival you
know like i have to neutralize this
threat
and then there's a moment where he can
actually use his rational brain and he
can and he can understand what's going
on i do like
if it's not about mrs landry then i like
the the symmetry
of that you know i i kind of brought
that up in my last video
and you know i was i was kind of
thinking about the you know i said it's
sort of like revenge or or justice for
irene and
you know i had a lot of people
who who were saying what but he but he
he you know he did the right thing at
the end of that and and i understand
that i was kind of thinking more about
the the pattern of him
being really comfortable with uh talking
to elderly ladies and and having a way
with you know being able to you kind of
get them to do what what he wants and
and how that is something is a blind
spot for him in this situation you know
at least that's how i was looking at
going in
and so you know
there is a symmetry there to like yeah
he
he did the one of the most awful things
that we remember him doing
in relation to irene and he did actually
feel bad about it because jimmy doesn't
always feel bad or or fix things so i do
like that i i don't know if um
you know if he would have if he would
have i don't i can't say that he
wouldn't have come to his senses
without that i mean i don't really think
he's a murderer like the kind of person
that does that in cold blood anyway
but um
i don't think that he was necessarily
bluffing either i think it's you know
it's a it's a fight-or-flight kind of
survival instinct and
you know she really was threatening his
existence you know exposing his uh
identity
yeah and i think it's it's an ambiguous
moment right there's not enough text in
the show to tell us for sure what was in
his mind i kind of have to tell myself
that he was bluffing
or maybe didn't quite know what he was
doing but would never have actually
crossed the line because if in his brain
he was
seriously considering strangling her and
killing her to me even if he didn't go
through with it that's kind of
irredeemable
to even have that in your list of actual
realistic options
to me that's
that's that's you've crossed the line at
that point
um so i guess it's ambiguous but i'd
like to believe he would never have gone
through with it
and i think we we have to watch the
final episode here and see what is the
final statement on jimmy mcgill how much
of a soul does he have left
and uh we'll see
yeah it's uh
ambiguous is the is the correct way to
look at it and like i was saying that a
little bit earlier you know there's so
much that you can't you can't know his
next move and every move that he makes
after that will dictate the end of this
story it you know it's a
it's a it's a it's a what are they
saying on the television news this is a
developing situation right and that's
where we're at right now we're we're
watching we're watching someone's life
you know
everything
the way that he's remembered and the way
that you know his legacy will all be
tied exactly to to the next couple of
decisions that he makes in in succession
in the next hour of tv
johan thank you for the five dollars
cops are coming quickly
marion knows him as gene takabic
does gene even have time to go back to
his combo for cash diamonds
it is an interesting question i i think
uh i don't think she knows where he
lives um
i don't know if they've ever referenced
that that her or jeff
you kind of think that he would keep
that to himself
he's not he's not um
he's pretty smart you know he's
careful but yeah he
he doesn't have long before the police
figure out where that's at
yeah
i think jeff drove him to his house
after the oh or no actually no he
stopped him yeah right you're right yeah
good point good point so yeah i think he
could make it back possibly but he would
have to move very quickly
uh whatever happens next i think we're
seeing a desperate person with very few
choices remaining so like we alluded to
earlier with where is he going to go
it'll be very interesting to see what
choice he makes
yeah and you watched the you saw the
little teaser that they they showed
after the mid credits thing right uh i
didn't see it are you talking i've seen
mention of the uh the esteem ripping
down the wanted poster is that what
we're talking about or something else
yeah it's the um the the the one and
poster one is a teaser that was out at
the beginning of the season and
uh tom schnell said that that actually
that some of that wasn't was just
manufactured by the marketing department
like that wasn't necessarily
something that we could look at as
something a scene that's going to come
up not canonical
yeah but the um
yeah at the end of the the last episode
in the mid-credits
kind of thing that they've been doing uh
they show the esteem and you hear jimmy
saying the words
for ed to disappear you know okay
but it's not there's no context of this
is him saying this right now or he said
it before or he's thinking about it you
know it it's all very vague and
um
you know i was just thinking about that
because i saw a lot of comments about
how
wouldn't it be crazy if he if his
instinct is to go back and get the
diamonds and try to run again
and he calls the the vacuum cleaner shop
and finds out that ed passed away and
that there's no one that actually took
his place like he calls and it's just
the vacuum cleaner store now you know
they're like okay hoover you know
pressure pros you know like we don't
know what you're talking about we don't
we don't carry that and and
that would be pretty insane
i saw i saw a theory uh a week a a few
days ago i think
that maybe kim
uh has become the new disappearer i mean
of course it's been disproven now but i
was like yeah okay so maybe you call up
and say you know i need a sprinkler
system 5000 and that's now the code so
clearly that hasn't proven true um but
if he calls ed again i feel like it's a
maybe a little bit of a cop-out for ed
to to no longer be there um obviously we
can't see him or hear him i understand
that but it feels like maybe it would be
a cop-out to just say that option is no
longer there for jimmy i feel like at
this point the most interesting thing is
to see what choices he's going to make
so maybe more interesting than that
would be the disappearer is available
but he finally chooses to face the music
yeah so i don't know i mean at the same
time we are currently watching all of
his options disappear right the cops are
after him so what's one more escape
route going away so i could see it going
that way as well
yeah but i i i like the idea that you
have there i think that it would make it
matter more if he chooses that rather
than he doesn't have a choice because
his first his first option didn't work
you know he couldn't he couldn't
disappear so
okay now i'll turn myself in that kind
of puts an asterisk on the end of the
series right what's saying i guess right
uh jonathan
gamble putty thank you for the 199. time
to sing and you know i was just thinking
when i was you know looking at this like
th this is such a dense episode and and
you can almost forget about this but
like she
if you look if you watch race seahorn on
that call
and and
how she musters up the the
the courage to just hang up the phone
you know what i mean
and then for them to have this this it's
time to sing like you know to go out and
and sing happy birthday to this other
character who happens to share a
birthday with with jimmy because
obviously she's talking to jimmy on his
birthday and it never gets brought up
but she gets you know whisked away into
the other room to to sing
and man it's just it's like i said
there's so many of these little moments
that you can kind of forget about it but
it is it was incredible it was a great
great shot i'm glad you brought this up
here johann
yeah powerhouse episode for ray seahorn
a aaron thank you for the 20 that's very
generous what do you think is gene's
primary motivation force behind all the
chaos in the last couple episodes hard
to connect the dots that led him to such
hostile behavior last episode with the
cancer guy and marion
my my my take on it is this is the way
that he copes with the the pain of of
you know what what's happened and and
you know i think they did a pretty good
job of
of uh emphasizing that this week
whenever you know they had his
they had them together in the um
in this uh his office there you know he
can't he can't face the reality of
what's happening so he he turns
to something else and
it's like an addiction you know he's
medicating himself
and it it it's the kind of situation i
think where it it has to escalate you
know the the the the phone call and the
way that it went down was so traumatic
to him
that he's just off the rails like he
just has to
distract his mind from from what's
what's actually you know
a very painful thing to look at
yeah and i think that's 100 right uh and
i hate to just go to the author intent
because it feels like cheating but i
think i i had this interpretation upon
viewing it because it parallels so
strongly with the creation of saul
goodman kim rejects him
that is kind of the final shred of hope
he has for acceptance when she rejects
him
it cuts to now he saw goodman so it's so
clearly established as his coping
mechanism we've seen flashes of it
before but now with this biggest gut
punch he's so firmly entrenched in this
character he's created
so i definitely had it in mind as a
coping mechanism so when we saw that
call i read it as rejection by kim
and
now he has to cope exactly like you said
he needs to go on another scam bender
and more desperately than ever before
because maybe he was holding on to some
faint hope that he could reunite with
kim at some point i mean you hear it in
his voice the fact that he can call her
and say hey just wanted to check in he
seems oblivious to the fact that there
is there's no chance of a
genuine reconnection between jimmy
mcgill and kim wexler so with this final
rejection
he he just goes off the rails he needs
to keep scamming and when they get to a
bump in the road where maybe they should
skip this one guy
he he can't he can't push the brakes
i think that's why we saw him in the rv
with
jesse and walt when they turn the lights
off and jesse asks about lalo that
drudges up all of that ptsd and trauma
for a moment he's jimmy mcgill again
scared of lalo salamanca so at that
point he says to walt you gotta try it
again i need to get back to the office
and get back to being a saul goodman so
i think with cancer guides another
example if he cannot push the brakes he
needs to keep going and the reason i
mentioned author intent earlier is
because tom schnauz has talked about
this where basically he'll say that the
rejection from kim on the phone opened
up the wound and as we've seen the way
he deals with it is by being saul
goodman now i do think there's an
ambiguous moment where when he's in the
guy's house he's taking the pictures
he can leave
but instead he decides to go make
himself a drink and uh hang out a bit so
why did he do that
and for me
there's a little jimmy mcgill voice deep
inside of his brain
that sees the path he's going down that
sees he's on a path of self-destruction
this is similar to the voice inside
kim's head that tells her to finally go
and confess i think that voice maybe
wants him to get caught some small part
of him so he's pushing the boundaries a
little bit i'll say that part of it i'm
still kind of processing but currently
that's how i'm viewing all this
yeah i i
i i kind of went back and forth on that
of like why he does that there i mean i
think there's the the
the high of it you know like he's
getting away with it like of course jeff
showed up on time just like i said he
would i can walk around this house i can
uh you know i can i
it doesn't matter i'm invincible kind of
thing
and and and then like you're saying he's
also being completely
like uh reckless compared to how what
we're used to so maybe there is some
underlying
thing about him wanting to get caught i
mean i know i've seen that
thrown around a lot it's not something
that naturally you know
came to me in the moment but when i look
when you when you when you try to make
sense of something it doesn't really
make sense like that's kind of
irrational
you have to at least think about you
know the that you have to at least bring
that into the equation i think um right
and you're talking about you know
just to get back to this question a
little bit before we move on it you know
you're talking about the the uh you know
authorial intent and
yeah they they have pretty much uh
has has said that and you know i i think
i you know in my videos leading up to
that you know i was coming to that
conclusion i i had i had been thinking
about that and in my mind it was a lot
more tragic you know the only reason i'm
bringing this up again is just because
it felt a lot more sad and tragic you
know especially after 609 and stuff like
that
and then when you see it in you know
just black and white like this is why we
did that
it sort of takes on a different um
you know it takes on a different tone
and it makes it you know makes you
wonder like exactly how how that
manifests itself in the finale going
forward
double dash
thank you for the two dollars kim time
equals wasted time so boring 80s style
wtf
80s style i'm not really sure about that
part um
definitely i definitely like the walter
sob check
icon you got there but can't agree with
the uh kim time equals wasted time um
yeah dash dash and i went back and forth
a bit last night um but he was literally
in the episode yeah but but we are kind
of buddies now because we uh we agreed
to disagree one of those rare things
that happens on the internet uh yeah but
yeah i just don't i just don't relate to
these comments at all i i i like i said
at the start of this i was on the edge
of my seat watching kim
i'm just fascinated by her character um
and and jimmy so yeah i loved the
episode um did not feel like the time
was wasted
do you understand what he's talking
about with the 80s style thing is that
yesterday is no that that's new to me is
i don't know if that's referring to uh
fat fashion choices i'm not a fashion
person i have no idea um yeah yeah i
really have no i just
don't know
yeah i'm not sure either
but thank you for the two there dash
dash uh mr g they made a point of
showing that kim won't make any
decisions she is purposely denying
herself agency in her own life for fear
that she will hurt someone yeah i i
wouldn't disagree with that
i mean it's not where i landed
right from the beginning but um
looking back now i do think that that's
the case um
and you know when we're talking about
jimmy this brings up this question here
too you know is jimmy doing is jimmy
trying to get caught is that a conscious
decision is that something that's going
on and then you know her not making
decisions here is that a conscious
decision or is that just a part of
uh you know
living this life and not trying to make
waves
right
yeah i know you you and i have kind of
already talked about the uh couple of
possible interpretations for why she's
doing all this and i definitely think
it's a mix of fear um she's seen what
happens when she kind of embraces
herself and makes choices
and also a mix of punishment self-exile
not allowing herself to be herself
because she carries so much guilt
yeah and i think on the inside of
podcast i was i was listening to that a
little bit when i was falling asleep
last night i think they were kind of
bringing up this idea or vince gilligan
was bringing up the idea of
penance you know
that she was
trying to do that and i i i wish i was
listening a little bit closer because i
don't know if he got to the to
to what's the mo like i understand
penance i just wonder if he was saying
that in relation to um
is she trying to achieve like is she
trying to atone is that is that what
they're saying whenever she she
eventually goes back to see cheryl you
know what i mean like
i didn't really get the full the full uh
idea about what he was saying
bear down adam thank you for the 499 the
divorce scene where jimmy is in full saw
mode was gut-wrenching i i totally agree
uh you know we're talking about our
experience of the episode i was really
mystified by what was happening in
florida
and obviously the end is super intense
and crazy and i was on the edge of my
seat for that but yeah the the first
thing that that really kind of stuck
the kind the thing that was kind of
hanging around in the back of my mind
that i just couldn't really shake was
that
that interaction in um in his office
that's in my video that's the first part
i talked about because
it you know it just it's affecting in a
way that it doesn't really make sense i
mean
you know obviously if you think about
those two characters you think of
everything that happened with them to
get them to that point
you know it's just
you don't even really know which one to
side with i guess it's sort of like you
know whenever you think about being like
a kid who's in a
you know who's being raised by uh
parents that that can't get along and
they have to separate or whatever and
and you know the the the kid is pulled
both ways
even if both parents are you know at
fault or whatever they there's still
that idea that this these people matter
to me and i don't want to see this
happen and uh that's kind of how i felt
with with watching that scene
yeah i mean it just it it really
crystallizes the idea that jimmy shields
himself from pain with the saul goodman
persona because he can't have a genuine
conversation with her because it's only
and what would that lead to right he he
can't be with her so he puts on that
saul goodman front and one thing that
occurred to me watching the episode that
i think is such a great choice they're
making in these in this final stretch
here is i kept wondering what more is
there to be said about the salt goodman
character once you know that it's a
coping mechanism it's a front we don't
really need to see any more of it
because we saw him in breaking bad
already um but i think what they've been
doing is just they're showing us the
saul goodman character and what it means
to different people we see what it means
to gene and how he kind of and i know
that they're the same person but how he
reflects back on that period of time
right right like i got news for you but
how how does he reflect back on those
times and how does he view saul goodman
and he views himself as paramount in
creating
what walter white became i think that's
what was part of what we saw last
episode and then in this episode we see
saul goodman
from kim's perspective
um and and i don't know at least i find
that it's an interesting approach and it
makes me wonder is there one final
morsel and i guess i think there is one
final morsel probably a scene with walt
in the final episode
yeah and there's so much there's so much
here um
i'm just gonna pull up this uh
8h
nic8 199. there's so much that um
man i there's that i'm still still just
sort of tossing around at ray's bus
scene equals greatest acting ever
breaking bad or bcs i mean that's a
pretty
there's a pretty strong statement but i
mean
you know
recency bias aside i i you know i think
it has to be in the contention you know
it has to be in contention for that i
mean it was
it was a wonderful scene and i really i
really liked the
the i i really like the choice to have
the person sitting next to her
put her hand on her you know on her arm
at the end to sort of offer some comfort
and
you know i i did listen to that i do
remember listening to that part of the
the insider podcast when they were
talking about how they shot this in in
one it's a oner they they they change
the the camera angle but it's just you
know two different it's one take with
two different uh camera angles of the
same shot
and um you know i i
i think like
the
just the the to be able to that whole
range of of the progression of of
breaking down and and just how how real
that felt
but then with that when you have the
hand come in
at the end the the stranger's hand it
it's just like
you know inside um kim wexler's brain
right there the character this made-up
character on the tv show that that that
she's we watched everything that was
going on in florida and her her thinking
that that's what she deserved you know
so you know that here
she doesn't
believe that she deserves that comfort
and and so you know like that that
little that little touch in the scene
really adds so much dimension and and
none of that works if it's not for the
way that ray seahorn you know was able
to deliver that and it's just amazing
performance
yeah not a lot for me to add because it
would just be me saying yeah incredible
performance i just i love the choice to
just
sit there and watch the entire
progression
uh incredible i love the moment of the
stranger
it's a it's an odd comparison but it
reminds me of spider-man 2 with all the
strangers on the subway helping
spider-man back on i'm such a sucker for
just seeing strangers show kindness
especially in this last stretch of
episodes where there's so much darkness
um just to see a genuinely kind moment
you know you see somebody in pain and as
a human being your instinct is to
give a helping hand
so
amazing scene
yeah
yeah it's one of those things you know
it
it
that whenever we think about things
there's so much stuff that gets in the
way but whenever we just react as as
human beings to to seeing something that
that looks like that you know that we're
a lot different in the way that we we
approach other people and and humanity
in in general
so yeah i agree with you on that like
the the stranger it might be a trope you
know like the the kind stranger but
people actually sometimes are
more
charitable as strangers than they are
whenever they they know exactly what's
going on and they make uh you know
calculated decisions or whatever well
said
brian worthington thank you for the ten
dollars pete do you think jimmy and kim
will see each other again in the final
episode well
i sort of started talking about this
earlier and got sidetracked but uh the i
i
my initial thought was that her story
was over but there was still more as far
as their story together and
you know make of that what you will i i
think i don't know if they were gonna i
don't know if they're gonna see each
other i don't know if we'll see them in
the same physical space
but i mean it's
it's ray seahorn we're just we're just
talking about
when you have her on your team if you
can figure out a way to get her into the
game in the final innings you know what
i mean like you need to try to do that
uh they didn't put her on the insider
podcast with the farewell
as far as i understand the talking saul
uh thing wasn't a farewell to the
character so
i think it's absolutely
for sure that she'll be in the last
episode but i don't know if that'll be
you know her doing things that affect
what jimmy will ultimately do
or if they will actually see each other
again what do you think gil
i
i always say that whatever choice they
make on the show i'm even if to me it
sounds like the wrong choice i'm sure
they'll find a way to do it where i say
that makes total sense but i'll say that
right now it's really hard for me to
imagine a satisfying conclusion or at
least for me personally it's hard to
imagine that i will feel satisfied if i
don't see these two characters together
and interacting one more time and i
think one thing i'm hoping to see
is jimmy reconcile with his past and
have we've seen him pull his emotions
out that may have some basis in reality
but they're always used as a tool like
we most recently saw with frank where he
has his breakdown but just to buy time
for jeff to get back up and get moving i
don't feel we've ever seen a really
genuine kind of confession sort of a
moment from jimmy and i think we have to
see that in the finale or at least i'm
hoping to see it and i don't know who
else it could be with besides kim who
else is left in his life that he could
have such an intimate conversation with
uh so
i i guess my gut tells me we need to see
them together one more time
but i always give the caveat that any
time i thought the show was going to go
right and it goes left i end up saying
in retrospect that makes total sense
and i have such an implicit trust in
these writers
yeah it would be it would be a baller
move if they didn't actually if they
didn't bring them back together i agree
with you and it sort of goes back to
what i was saying earlier you know
these characters do what they they that
make sense for them to do but then
there's this whole thing of like i want
them to do things too you know what i
mean and and in my mind certain things
are much more satisfying than others and
it does it seems like it would be really
unsatisfying for them not to come back
together but like i said i think she was
going back to florida i mean that she's
on the she we may find out that after
her
her cry
that that she decided not to go back to
florida that's a possibility but it
wasn't that i didn't feel like
you know
tonally that's what that was saying i i
felt like it you know she did the best
she could as far as as being responsible
for what happened and it wasn't perfect
and
and you know she couldn't even
really
deliver closure
there's a possibility that you know in
the short term she she she even kind of
uh
opened up some some wounds again and and
and couldn't really you know make it
make that right because
it didn't sound like they'll actually
prosecute her either without you know
some kind of witness coming up or
something you know what i mean so
it's uh
yeah but i mean
i don't know but
i can't wait to see you yeah
hey they're not afraid to use
tropes like we've seen with the kind
stranger we could get the romantic
comedy gene chasing after the airplane
as she prepares to take off for florida
the cops are chasing after him it could
happen
yeah you know yeah i was thinking i i
was reading alan steppenwall's uh
review this morning and he brought up
something that i that i hadn't thought
about
i'm trying to find how to summarize it
pretty short but he was basically saying
that um
he you know jimmy wants to see her again
so bad what he actually
you know put would he actually bring her
into what's going on with him getting
caught just so he can see her one more
time does that make sense i mean
it's a it's a bit of a paragraph there
he says will she see him again i would
not bet against kim being in the finale
not after how crucial she's become to
the series while talking to cheryl kim
acknowledges that jimmy saul jean is the
one who can corroborate her story
these last two episodes have established
that he is desperate to see her again
and that he responds to her
understandable refusal to do so in the
worst possible ways
after and this installment concludes
with jeff's mother marion ratting gene
out to the authorities in a manner that
could well bring him back to the scene
of his many crimes
under those circumstances would he be
willing to put kim in legal jeopardy
just as an excuse to see her again
uh yeah
that would be a pretty that would be a
pretty insane twist i think if he's just
like you know i'm going to jail anyway i
just wanted to see you one more time
right would it put her only i guess i
can imagine ways to approach that
without putting her in legal jeopardy
um kind of like we saw with walt when he
called skyler and was like what did you
have to do with this nothing right
there's a way to interact with her that
doesn't put her in legal jeopardy um
where the the from an outsider
perspective it would appear that he is
an antagonist maybe she's there
unwillingly
even though
on the inside they're having a
conversation for the last time and then
he gets taken away i guess i don't
necessarily take it that
that him seeing her means she's in legal
jeopardy
yeah i think what he's saying though is
that
would he go that far
isn't when
to put her in legal jeopardy as well
yeah would he choose to do that in order
just just so that he can see her one
last time before he goes down for his
crimes i see what you're saying okay
yeah okay that's an interesting idea
that would be um
i guess i wouldn't be too happy with him
if he did that no
no one in
no one
who's watching it would be i mean i mean
i guess there would be some sadist who
would think like yeah that's
good or something but
it would be ant you know it would be one
of those things that you would it would
be very hard to to to square inside your
head but it would also kind of make
sense for what we saw in the last few
episodes you know he's willing to go to
crazy lengths to kind of not feel that
what is he you know what is he willing
to go to to actually
to see her one more time because it's
pretty obvious that at least where they
left things on the last phone call she
doesn't want that to happen she's not
open to that happening
8 hn ic8 thank you for the 199 again
this is the best bcs episode
equals me after the last six episodes i
think for me the high points were 7 9
and 12. i don't think that the other
ones that followed ever i never really
put them higher on the list um
but yeah they it's been but i think
what's more important than like any
individual episode being you know the
best or whatever is just that it's all
felt like a a meaningful progression
towards something
that's going to be satisfying
at the end you know
yeah no
second all of that
yeah i'm not sure i mean i i'm never
great at ranking i don't really like
doing it because i'm i i get
so caught up in whatever i'm doing at
the moment that i'm i'm really bad with
recency kind of stuff like i
because i you know that's that's the way
i like to
enjoy things is to like kind of be like
as as
absorbed in it at the moment as i can be
you know craig otto thank you for the
ten dollars please reflect on the fact
that howard's death is having an impact
on the end of this story glad there will
be record of it even if it's not
prosecuted
have you re-watched his final scene
since uh yeah i've watched it a lot of
times
both in you know making clips and just
sort of
you know before the second half of the
season started i rewatched the whole
first half just to kind of you know
get back into that that headspace
and yeah i mean you know i i don't think
it's it's terribly important
uh
as far as
as
you know beyond what what it's what it's
doing to the characters and it has been
doing a thing it's sort of like when you
think of their lives there's like sort
of before howard after howard you know
and that's that's what we're seeing and
you know we're taught all of what we're
talking about about like why is kim
doing this why is kim living this way
that's all
exactly about howard's death
yeah i mean i've been
since his death thinking about the end
of this series
um this is on that list of things that i
felt was necessary for a satisfying
conclusion
if there's any hope of you know
redemption for either of these
characters
uh or any hope of us leaving the series
without looking at both of them as just
they succumb to evil
and i i am just i'm not happy with
either of these characters a confession
had to happen the record had to be set
straight um and specifically i think it
had to be set straight for cheryl uh you
know plus the public but i think her
first and foremost give her closure as
much as possible so uh yeah i'm very
glad to see that it's still having an
impact not just in the sense that it
brought these characters here but as
craig pointed out it's explicitly having
an impact and explicitly being addressed
i think that was very important and i'm
glad that we're seeing it
what a little mini arc for for cheryl
hamlin huh
yeah i mean three three scenes and and
and totally
right there with her at the end whenever
kim's there you know
yeah with her and and also for howard i
mean we've of course seen a lot more of
him but it's interesting how for howard
and for cheryl they've shown us little
snippets of these characters lives just
kind of little check-ins you know with
howard we saw this whole arc that just
played
off-screen where he has insomnia he's
completely falling apart and then he
basically did what jimmy should have
done he went and he got help and he
dealt with his emotions
he got that namaste license plate we saw
him do a total 180.
and we saw similar
similarly with cheryl just a couple of
snippets but you feel like you're
absorbing this kind of
off-screen arc for that character
it's the way that better call saw in
breaking bad are so good at making even
characters that don't appear on screen
very much making them feel very real and
their lives don't go on pause just
because we're not seeing them
dskc gaming thank you for the two
dollars no oath line yet kim goes
d a to put an end to it um
i feel like uh
i feel like any idea about her becoming
a lawyer again
i i wasn't a big fan i mean i understand
that there was that that teaser i wasn't
really a big fan of this idea in my in
my head i think after this um
i mean do you think that there is a turn
like that is there room for a turn like
that would a turn like that makes sense
would you like to see kim the color come
back into kim's life and and her make a
big uh shift i mean her helping jimmy
seems really
really kind of contrived in a way at
this point
yeah and i'll definitely agree with that
that her helping jimmy would feel
i mean she kind of helped him right by
leaving it ambiguous
of uh if he's you know i i think he's
still out there or he might still be
alive but her taking an active role in
helping him yeah
that that feels like a bridge too far
um
yeah i heard her becoming a lawyer again
feels unlikely but i guess if you were
to imagine a happy ending
it would be her
figuring out a way to move on
and
kind of
realize that she can be a lawyer and
make choices and pick the mayonnaise
that she wants without getting someone
killed that would be the happy ending
and if this were real life it wouldn't
seem impossible
um but i don't know at this point
they've trained me not to expect happy
endings so who knows
yeah um
yeah like i i said i i i just don't
i i it's a good i the first time i
watched it i didn't really pick up on
the idea that she does sort of shield
him there when she says if he's still
alive um
and then there is a bit of that but yeah
i agree with what you're saying there to
for her to take the active role that is
that would seem out of character i i
think um
and i don't know that that i don't know
how that would benefit his his his
ending because we want him to
we want him to be able to break through
this coping mess mechanism and finally
face this stuff that's been you know
eating him up and and you know we're
talking about the torturous uh existence
before
her her being able to uh fix that it
just doesn't seem like something i want
to see
francisco chung
thank you for the 5
900
i believe that's korean
korean currency uh imagine if jesse
decided not to stick with saul or if
saul had listened to mike's advice
downfall of saul walter and jesse could
have been avoided
yeah i mean
i agree
in a way you know you can make the same
argument about
you know
what if saul didn't go in to the high
school what if kim told uh jesse to to
walk away and that that saul was not a
good lawyer and you don't want his his
representation
you know it it all comes back to what we
were saying earlier though when we were
talking about this and that you know a
lot of these things
you know these are these characters they
they're they're going to get to places
one way or the other you know
sure anything could change along the way
but um
you know it as a thought experiment okay
you could you could think of this but
you know the the story isn't that if
that hadn't happened then then these
things you know then the world would
have been a better place or something
it's just the way that all these things
interact with each other and you know
from my perspective
yeah and it's such a compliment to this
show though that you can play those kind
of mental experiments where you can
trace everything back to a series of
choices and events
even other shows that i love like take a
show like mad men it's hard for me to
point at a specific choices don draper
made
he made so many kind of different
consistent but unrelated choices where i
can't point to one and say oh what if he
had gone left instead of right
and i'm sure there are instances of that
in the show but i feel like with
breaking bad and better call saul it's
just it's so clear and it's so focused
on such a small limited set of
characters
that you can really explicitly see all
the domino pieces
yeah and you know and
actions have consequences that that is a
that's a true thing but i think it's
more on the you know you look at that on
the individual and how
how that how those consequences affect
them and and then
you know inform further decisions that
they make down the road
binkyboy10 thank you for the 4.99 euro
do you think there is a chance or a
change that this show will end with
solemn prison and do you think it's
possible that bill oakley will defend
him in court
i mean they did show that bill became a
defense attorney so that would be a
little more palatable than than kim i
guess at this point
but yeah i mean i think it could end
with saul in prison he's definitely
wanted
uh marian did um
you know
call him in uh he's on the run
he either has to escape
die or end up in prison and you know
it's going to be one of those three it's
it's inevitable
what do you think about that and bill
being his uh
his um
he's a defensive attorney yeah yeah i
mean at this point it feels like saul in
prison is the
most is kind of the happiest possible
ending for the series
which is as weird to say
um i'd love to see bill show up
and defend him
but
i don't know it feels like there's not a
lot of real estate left
can we in one episode
get to jeans on the run he gets caught
he gets to court bill's defending him it
just feels like a lot
feels like a stretch but would i love to
see it sure
yeah
and i just realized i saw this one two
on the last one that we were doing but i
didn't see the two when i initially
scrolled down so okay let's read this
whole thing out uh imagine if jesse
decided not to stick with saul or if
saul had listened to mike's advice
downfall of
saul walter and jesse could have been
avoided
and then the second one when i
cur go down here past binky boy 10
is
maybe in the final episode we'll find
out how walter's decision could have
made a difference love your show thank
you
you want to you want to
i just uh scrolled all the way through
here do you want to address that gil
yeah well i think it just
recalibrate myself here yeah it goes
along with what we were saying before i
mean there are so many domino pieces you
can point to and say what would have
happened if this one didn't fall
um
though in this case i would say there is
a lot of inevitability with some of
these characters that i think let's say
that
walt didn't go with saul or jesse didn't
go with saul uh walt i think you called
them kind of an unstoppable force of
nature earlier i think that he was
powering through
and and would have found a way i think
it's important that saul views himself
as a decision maker in that process that
he was the one that went and pulled
pulled walt out of the minor leagues uh
i think saul views himself that way
i agree with that too yeah but i don't
think that means that without saul's
intervention it wouldn't have happened
anyway some other way
yeah and i think it's it's
i i guess it's possible that this is
what the walt appearance will be next
episode some kind of rumination on how
things could have gone otherwise
uh but yeah it feels like it's more
about
waltz than it does about saul so i'm not
sure that's what we're gonna see
uh and better i'm not sure that's what
we're gonna see in the finale but we'll
see
yeah i've been kind of flip-flopping
since i've been reading this and
i think you put it pretty pretty well
right there it does seem a little bit
more about walt you know
um
but we'll see thank you again francis
chung for the question uh jack within
jack within thank you for the 199 did
saul have mike find kim's whereabouts in
florida
no i don't think so because
in the in the when they're in the office
he says so florida and he won't even let
her get it out about why why there and
then he doesn't even let her answer the
question it doesn't matter
but he knew about it before she went
there i mean i think that was the
implication the timeline's a little
fuzzy there um
because he on the phone he says it's
been six years it's been six years since
they broke up
but then she comes back to do the the
the paper sometime in between
the only thing i could say for sure is
it's after he remodeled his office um
and before he starts
working with walter white because
obviously
jessie's there with um
emilio emilio and that's before that's
before season one and
a a fair amount of time before it could
be or it could be right before that you
know what i mean so
it's hard to say so i think no i don't
think he used mike i think that they
that they had some contact with each
other
maybe just when she said hey look i'm
moving to florida we need to get
um
you know divorce store i'm back i've
been living in florida and i just need
to get this divorce taken care of before
i go back there or whatever and that's
how he found out yeah it just also
doesn't feel like like we said earlier
she's not exactly hiding uh if you
wanted to find her it just it doesn't
feel like you'd need a pi or a mike
herman trout to do that
the white pages might be fine yeah i
mean she works
this is a time you know of
land lines which we saw
an example of there and and white pages
you know you used to just be able to
look up someone's number pretty pretty
simply if you wanted to if you knew
where they were
calling the operator i was thinking
about that on when he's in the pay phone
you know so like
you know when was the last time that
that was even possible to do like that
you know maybe maybe 12 years ago
the period piece aspects of the show are
so fun i see yeah i mean youtube has
been around for i guess about four years
when uh marion is looking at the cat
videos but you definitely see the early
days of it it's fun
yeah
pablo asuna thank you for the 4.99 who
else has the same costco trash can as
kim
lol on a serious note gonna miss your
bcs breakdowns just as much as the
episodes thanks for everything
uh i do not have that trash can do you
have that um
gil i don't believe i do i'm gonna have
to re-watch the scene um but uh
you know what now that i think about i
didn't get my trash can at costco i
definitely didn't sell so i guess not
yeah
yeah and
um
i didn't notice that it it was one of
those conspicuous things but i i didn't
remember ever having that exact same one
um
i i
i guess we didn't really touch on the
boyfriend much
um and he's the one that's taking out
the trash there
i mean it
nothing wrong with the guy right you
know what i mean but what a strange
thing to to have him saying yep while
they make love um
for that to be a big part of this
character is it's a really strange
string i didn't mention that when i made
the video just because
it didn't really fit with any of the
other stuff that i was talking about
with her
but uh it's a strange tick you know you
were talking about earlier about how
even the insignificant characters they
find a way to make them you know
interesting and memorable and that's
yeah and that that's that one is what
i'll remember about that guy i mean as
much as uh vince gilligan it keeps
saying you know it's nothing
intrinsically wrong with the life kim's
living i mean i feel like every time i
say that i'm playing a little bit of
mental gymnastics jumping over some of
these things
yeah i mean he they could have they
could have shown it in a way more
neutral light if they if they weren't
wanting us to uh
their boyfriend her boyfriend did not
have to to say that during uh
intercourse
if if they wanted that to be more normal
looking that's right joe luzzy thank you
for the 199 why did francesca not seem
happy to see kim
i thought about this a little bit you
know i think one of the things about
francesca is that i think about
differently
one of the things i think
about
i look i look at her a little bit
differently because i know that she
listens to saul goodman 24 hours a day
now as he's
trying to cope with
you know what what he's doing as he's
using this this method of being
full-blown all the time always on the
headset
talking to francesca to deal with life
she has to deal with that all the time
and i i don't know
if there was something else implied
there but i feel like
her i feel like you know in a vacuum
francesca's um
progression as a character makes sense
but i did think that was a little bit
weird that there wasn't some moment
where she was sort of like
hey kim sorry that went that way or
something you know right did you pick up
on anything like any other implication
there gil i don't know the overriding
thing for me was just that this is
probably a very uncomfortable situation
um yeah so it's it's hard to tell
looking at the mix of stuff francesca's
feeling in that scene how much of that
is specifically directed at kim versus
just this is really awkward and
uncomfortable i'm beaten down because
i'm sick of this saul goodman guy and
now i'm about to watch this woman who i
once respected
uh have to face this
just
scummy version of the man she once loved
and she has to kind of stand there in
between it
so i can imagine why there wouldn't be a
lot of warmth there
um
but yeah i might just have to rewatch
the scene but that was kind of the
overriding thing for me
yeah and i didn't i didn't think about
it while i was watching but just now
when you were talking i was i was just
realizing that
he was there for an hour
he made kim sit outside for an hour
right so they they could have it could
have just been as simple as they had
that conversation off off screen because
you can tell that francesca is is really
in a hurry to get out of there once she
talks to him and she wants him to bring
her in so they can get it over with and
move on
so it could be it could be referring to
that as well that you know that yeah
she's just she's just stressed because
they've been there so long and now
she wants to get out of there and they
already talked outside yeah that's a
very good point yeah
crates clouds thank you for the 4.99
where do you think the writers get the
scams from research or actual crimes
uh
i mean it's a good question if you
listen to the insider podcast they they
they do provide a lot of details i can't
think of anything specific about um
about any of the the um
the scams though off the top of my head
i can think of one actually uh okay one
instance where they got a scam from real
or kind of a scam but the travel wire of
uh somebody going through the roof i
think and then to the other side i
believe they said they read about that
happening somewhere and that's where
they got the idea that's that's the one
example i could think of
but but otherwise
i know that in general they talk about
how
they they take a lot of time planning
this stuff out and just bounce a lot of
ideas in the writer's room um and kind
of flesh them out but that's at least
one example where i can think of
inspiration coming from real life
yeah i mean the obvious one that always
comes up when i think about
actual crimes and and sort of real real
life stuff is that
tom schnauz read the article about the
um
people making meth in the rv and then he
talked to vince gilligan and that that
sort of became the idea for the show for
breaking bad
but um you know i do remember them
saying that you know they that they
none of them have ever done this sort of
stuff but they pull off of of you know
other similar things that happen in like
those kinds of environments you know i
mean like if you think about um
you know you think about the last scam
at the mall
he's basically
you know the the way that they dictate
that is they're like okay the who is the
character
he's really good at at using what's
available to him so what's available to
this guy in the mall setting and then
you go from there you know like what
would he be able to do you know in that
in that situation
joe luzzi thank you for the 4.99 do you
think it's possible kim ever kim never
filed divorce papers and therefore has
to decide if she has to testify against
jimmy or not
i saw this quite a bit in the comments
uh in my video yesterday after last
night whenever i uploaded and
i've never been a big fan of the
courtroom the the final courtroom
showdown thing i i kind of think it
it would just be it'd make more sense if
jimmy's you know it to me it's about
whether jimmy makes the decision to
take responsibility more than what
happens after that fact so i don't
really
think about these kind of scenarios um
nothing that we saw in that scene made
it like okay
maybe she's not gonna file these
it's really like you're working
backwards i think from the idea that
that might have been important for how
they got married in the first place was
because of the spousal privilege so
you're trying to
get to a place where it would make sense
for her to do that but in the scene
itself
there's nothing to tell us that she's on
the fence about filing the papers or
that talking to him or talking to
you know
jesse might have changed her mind on
that did you do you think
no i mean i agree with everything you
just said um and we've brought up the
idea a few times now of this ending in
court somehow and
now that we're approaching the final
episode logistically it feels tough for
me to get there i feel like there's not
enough room we've of course seen time
skips
so it's possible
but i don't know i just i have a hard
time picturing it at this point
yeah it's a longer episode i know i
don't know exactly how long i haven't
seen it or anything like that um
but i i did see that the run time is is
significantly longer but not like an
hour and a half or anything it's like
maybe 60 minutes instead of
47 or something like that
oscar alvarez thank you for the 499. i
think that the 730k in the bank account
is a foreshadowing that saul will switch
walter's mind from 737 is enough
to i'm in the empire business um
i i i mean it could be but i mean i
think
it's been a while since i rewatched
breaking bad but i mean he had a pretty
organic uh
you know that that happened pretty
organically him making that choice and
he got he got something out of being
heisenberg about the respect that that
came with and the fear and everything
else
i don't know what how jimmy could really
affect that really you know i mean i
think that's about who he is in his
nature and and and what this situation
allowed to come out you know not not so
much of like him making a decision
737 is enough is the kind of thing that
you tell yourself like when you want to
do something wrong you know you want to
say oh it's this is wrong but you know
hey i'll i'll only do it this one time
because i'll get this thing that i need
and then i'll walk away from it and just
it just doesn't really work like that
yeah yeah i think this would be another
way of telling us that saul once again
views himself as kind of paramount in
the journey walt took and i think they
already told us that in a way that
doesn't diminish any of walt's choices
because saul did there was no bearing on
that saul didn't convince
well saul did convince walt to do
something but it was more logistics it
had nothing to do with walt's ambitions
and what he wanted to accomplish
this feels a little bit like it risks
taking away from everything you just
said about walt how he had had that
organic transition from
i'm doing it for the money to why am i
really doing this do we need to see that
saul had something to do with that
i'm not sure that we do so so i'm not
sure about that one
yeah
pablo vasquez thanks you oh thank you
for the ar
20 dollars could the cry and confession
be a plan to defend jim
well currently there is no defending jim
unless jim turns himself in so
i guess we'll cross that bridge when we
come to it because
i i don't think that's i think that was
her
the her crying i think was her her
realizing it you know the feeling that
that
the weight had been lifted of carrying
that around for six years you
know i think we're seeing her
be able to experience that emotion that
she tried to keep uh buried you know and
we see
jimmy trying to keep that buried and
it's coming out in all these crazy ways
of him him doing
all of what he's doing and uh hers came
out in a more natural and healthy way as
she cried on on the shuttle bus
kik01 thank you for the five dollars
love new and old jeff but on the insider
podcast gould hinted the recast changed
the direction of the story
will we ever find out what that plot was
uh i didn't i didn't hear this um
i heard in the in the one last week
tom chanel said that they actually wrote
the part for don harvey they didn't
write it for pat healy um
so this is this is co this is conflict
this is in conflict with the information
that i had already absorbed so i i can't
really speak to it um
yeah no
yeah
because they wrote this is the one time
in the in the history of this show that
they wrote
all of the they broke the entire story
before
they started filming
you know i mean so in the past
they might have been able to adapt and
change a little bit after they got to
know the actor and what you know
you know the meeting with uh you know
the meeting with kim and uh
jesse as an example that of two
characters who got much expanded roles
after they saw what they could do but i
don't think this is my understanding on
this situation was that it it there
wasn't really much
there wasn't really much that they could
actually change it was they wrote it for
one actor they couldn't get him they got
somebody they thought would do a good
job and i think that he mostly has
so torchington thank you for the 9.99
good to see you heard bill burr say that
three comedian actors saul qb and huell
on breaking bad we're holding down the
best drama on tv for a scene in saul's
office i feel the same about odin kirk
and carol burnett last night
yeah i don't
carol burnett is is considered a
fantastic
legendary actor but i don't know of much
drama that she's done um and so it's
pretty amazing to see that in her late
80s i mean i remember seeing a law and
order or something like that where she
was uh in a different kind of you know
in a more serious kind of uh role and
and she was great at it
but i don't think that that that's a
part of you know her her catalog per se
you know
i i did think that they did a great job
with what they had and um you know it
was it was one of those things that like
it was kind of inevitable we knew that
you don't really bring her in there just
to be the sweet old lady drinking
schnapps but um
she rose to the occasion definitely yeah
definitely
radio chaos thank you for the five
dollars canadian
kim jay but look kim gave up jimmy in
the scheme but still lied when she
didn't know if he was alive or dead yeah
we just touched on this that wasn't
something that was immediately apparent
to me
just because i was like so like
you know mesmerized with what might
happen in that in that but it's
something that does come up after the
fact and uh gil touched on it before
let's see here francesco faulty thank
you for the 199
euro don't you think the jesse cameo was
unnecessary
sorta yeah but you know like i said they
they pretty much the writers had said
that they did it because they wanted to
do it and it made sense and
gill touched on a little bit and it's
one of the things that i said in my
video you know it these two characters
are very similar in the space that they
occupy in their than the respective
series and
there's a natural you know it it makes
sense for them to to share the screen
as far as who they are and and
and then in that you know
in that role or whatever but the plot
may not have dictated it but i didn't i
you know i thought it worked fine just
anyways because
you know it wasn't it wasn't that
unbelievable
albuquerque is a small town these people
would interact with each other on some
levels and you know those are all things
that were set up in the story that they
could they could pull on if they wanted
to
nava down south thank you for the five
dollars the cheryl will feel any guilt
for howard's death she she seemed to
treat him badly like the coffee poor
spill in his file final days
um you know
i think that that was one of the really
really
gutting parts of of episode 609 was
seeing
you know kim
gaslight her and and kind of make sure
that she felt some guilt for howard's
death at least and not under you know
not seeing his addiction
um
i'm not sure you know we
we don't know enough to know like what
he did why there was that rift in their
relationship we just know that they had
that um
but yeah i think you know it's
i think it's reasonable to say that
that she
that anytime something unexpected like
that happens that you're gonna feel some
some guilt yeah
craig otto thank you for the five
dollars
pete is it nice to not have gus in the
last few episodes so you don't
accidentally call guild gus
yeah thanks for for
this is probably going to do that now
uh please have an all-star blowout for
the last episode
yeah um
i think i'm busy next week uh you know i
don't know
i'm just kidding i'll be here yeah yeah
i mean i'm going to uh
i i the last couple weeks i've been uh
i've been really kind of stretched thin
and um
it's been a little bit hard to plan
ahead but i i do want to
this is a big event that's coming up so
i'm gonna you know
and i appreciate the people that have
come on and and talked to me so i'm
gonna try to get everyone involved
in one
one way or the other but um i'm not
exactly sure what that looks like but
yeah it's nice to not have
too much gust bouncing around in there
because
for some reason when i see the word and
i i i try to say gill's name i i absorb
it and they they get mixed together
88n ic8 thank you for the 199. thought
the young pd kim sees in albuquerque was
esposito yeah i've seen um i've seen
that bouncing around i saw that on
a couple you pointed out on twitter
i went and looked at the credits she's
not credited the the actor the actor
that played her is not credited and
there's nobody
in there that that
there's no way that i could find to um
to verify that
it's a good idea but i don't know if
it's the truth or not
can jaworski thank you for the 4.99
jerome giorno thank you for the five
dollars i feel like the last episode is
going to end with the big trial against
jimmy kim testifying i think science
fell finale but more depressing
yeah we've answered this a couple times
recently um
i don't really have much else to say
about it if if it happens it happens but
i i don't it's not
it's not what i expect to see
and i i kind of
then i don't mean to just brush it off
but i was i was trying to remember
exactly how the the seinfeld finale
played out and and i and i i can't do
you have anything to add on this
on the seinfeld front um they they
basically
the uh the characters in that show were
obviously known for being pretty cynical
toward their fellow man so there was uh
somebody that i think was getting robbed
or something and they filmed him and
were kind of just laughing at him so
under a new good samaritan law they all
get arrested put on trial and they use
the trial as a way to bring back like
all the supporting characters who appear
in the series over time to kind of give
testimony about their character talk
about all the awful things they've done
and then they end up in prison spoilers
for seinfeld
yeah i remember that they ended up and i
remember that nobody it seemed to be
like it was not a popular finale when it
happened not happy with it
yeah but i couldn't remember the details
and i think that that that kind of
brings me back up to speed
jay diaz thank you for the five dollars
could jimmy really possibly wind up in
belize lol
i think it's possible
he's on a distract he's on a
self-destructive bent you know
yeah it's like you said before it's
either escape prison or death escape
feels hard to imagine because we we kind
of already saw escape and now we're in
the aftermath of that are they just
going to do that again so it feels like
prison or death is what it feels like i
feel like that's what they want us to be
thinking
so i don't know it's hard to see where
they're going with this
there's always the option that
it's it picks up in the next episode and
he comes back into the to marion's
uh
you know house and and he gives her a
big long deep kiss and it turns out to
be that they they escaped together
as could be
a completely different romance that we
didn't see coming yeah because i think
there's a little bit of chemistry there
i could be wrong but i think
there's something there's good they can
build something there
jimmy goodman thank you for the you 499
euro
what do you think the significance of
opening season six with saul's house and
the bottle cap was
can't believe there's one episode left
what a show
well i think it was a tease um
saul's house was not something that
we were familiar with and so whenever he
wakes up there in 609 and and they may
not even have constructed it this way
but it worked this way that whenever we
have that that that abrupt cut uh from
from the trauma of losing kim straight
into him being saul goodman
spinning around on the uh the rotating
bed with a
hooker um
i think it i think it it makes sense for
us to already kind of know where he's at
when we see that otherwise we're like is
he in a hotel is he
you know is it like what where where
exactly is he doing this um
and the bottle cap i i think it was for
us to
you know to to wonder
to kind of know that kim wasn't going to
be in his life and the house also does
that a bit because it's so gaudy and
it doesn't seem to have any of her
touches uh you know whenever we go
through it
but the bottle cap was just you know a
way for us to think about
how could that how could that be how
could how could her trophy of their time
together that that she kept for all
those seasons how would she leave that
behind and what would that mean
yeah and i think in ret i think a lot of
people interpreted it as and i think
it's tear credit i think this is the way
you saw it initially is that kim's
probably not around and jimmy kept it as
a keepsake and now in retrospect it
tells us that he held on to it clearly
he was still holding on to
the memory of kim and i think we're
seeing the payoff to it now
i think if he had already let go of any
hope of a reunion with kim
then her rejection
a couple of episodes ago wouldn't have
sent him off the deep end the way it did
he he he was still holding on to hope he
got rejected and now he's going on this
reckless bender if he didn't have hope
he maybe wouldn't have even reached out
to her or if he did and got rejected it
wouldn't have mattered
so uh so i think the stopper is sort of
a visual representation of that idea
yeah
and and
you know i i don't want to i don't want
to go to a rabbit hole because um a lot
of questions behind here but
you know it it i i i'm not sure it makes
100
sense
of how
how he saved a lot of that stuff like
some of that stuff was like future
easter eggs some of it was just straight
up easter eggs
i'm not 100
sure that that if you really think about
it
hard it it makes sense you know like
because
you know he kept all these different
memories of scams and things and and
that tells us that it's an important
part of his life and it's something that
he looks back on in the absence of of of
being jimmy mcgill of being having his
life with kim but does it really make
sense for the character to keep his his
shoes from the mall and
all these other mementos from things
that he did wrong if he's still actively
you know create you know committing
crimes right
carl borchers thank you for the
kim running away to florida and taking a
job beneath her reminds me of mcmurphy
in china beach leaving nursing
and working at the orange factory and
hooking it up with gatorman a guy she
didn't love unfortunately i have no idea
what any of that stuff you're talking
about is
you
well pete obviously china beach is a
drama from 1988 that ran for four
seasons starring dana delaney uh i've
just googled it on my other tab yeah
it's going to say
impressive oppressive recall there
but yeah i i didn't watch it i don't
know
i mean that sounds very similar so yes
i'm kind of curious i'm at least going
to look at the wikipedia article about
this show later because that's
intriguing if they're that similar
well hopefully yeah hopefully there's
other people in the chat who have seen
it and you can and you guys can uh you
guys can discuss it
and i'll just have to say thank you for
the 9.99 because i that's about all i
can say
uh word nerd
nice rhyming name 7-eleven thank you for
the 20. that is very generous kim's sad
life in florida is her self-inflicted
penance
for the most punishment she can inflict
on herself until she gets saul's call
he helps her figure out the real step
towards redemption the confession love
you guys all right well thank you for
that and
you know it's it's kind of funny because
he's just throwing it out there like why
don't you turn yourself in
and then she's sort of like okay that
does make a lot of sense now that you
bring it up
i do wonder if um him saying that
fring's dead
lalo's apparently dead he's still a
little bit afraid of lalo but you know
he believes he's dead mike's dead i do
wonder if that that and can those two
things in in conjunction you know those
two things working together
if that is part of why she did it you
know what i mean because
going back to albuquerque before
you know i mean she did walk up to gus
springs house with a gun you know what i
mean um
and she would have seen that in the news
so it's not like him saying it is
necessarily the thing but but the fact
that they are all dead you know i wonder
if that has par something to do with it
too you know yeah i i think it it it
might um but i i i don't necessarily
think that diminishes her choice to go
confess and i'm not saying you're saying
that
um but i i think she probably thinks it
diminishes it i think her confession
maybe feels a little bit hollow
um
but i
a few episodes ago when i was i was kind
of thinking out loud that it would be
nice for kim to have walked away
she made the right choice she learned
her lesson maybe she gets to go be happy
and some people replied saying you know
why does she get off scot-free i think
that's a fair point she she if she wants
true redemption she needs to to confess
but there was a time there where
confessing may have meant a debt
sentence right if she knows too much
like you said she went to gus's house
with a gun intent on shooting him and i
don't i don't think execution is a
fitting punishment for her crime
right as much as we say she had a role
in howard's death she did not commit
murder she she did something bad
that happened to lead to howard's death
but lalo pulled the trigger so
she needs to
confess she needs to incur some sort of
punishment for what she did but i don't
think it's death so i think it's
complicated so i do think that may have
been in the mix i can now go confess
because all those people are dead
and also
it's a reminder of
there is a thing that you should do if
you really want to do the right thing so
i think both are in the mix
um but like i said i don't think it
diminishes the choice necessarily
yeah and there's something to be said
for not doing well like understanding
that you did something wrong and then
not doing it again
true yeah like true the way that she's
living and and you know it's been the
idea of penance is out there and all
that stuff self uh imposed exile
but that is a you know that's not
nothing you know like if you do
something terrible
and then you make it your point to never
do it again that's a lot more than a lot
of people a lot of people will ever do
and and it also solves the problem of
that not happening again you know right
yeah
yeah yeah kenny jordarsky thank you for
the 499 maybe he turns himself in but no
charges can stick for various reasons
and he goes free with nowhere left to go
maybe
i think that
and i think that they would be able to
make
charges stick against um
against uh gene saul jimmy because
they got all this all the shell
companies you know we kind of got that
information last episode that they they
found all the money he squirreled away
uh it sounds like there was a paper
trail
i don't think this is the same situation
as there being no evidence about what
happened to howard i think they they do
actually have some some stuff on on
saul what do you think
no no i agree i mean the fact that
they're still following francesca and
they're so intent on finding saul i
think they have a solid case the only
thing they're missing
is saul himself
yeah
trader chris thank you for the 9.99 why
did saul go into hiding in the first
place the only person that connect him
is walt's wife
which wouldn't say anything because of
her paralyzed boss
so how would he become a person of
interest um
you know this is a thing that comes up
over and over again and i you know
i'll just defer to what what the what
the writers have said
recently uh because i mean this never
was a question to me he was obviously
you know doing a lot of the
facilitating of a criminal enterprise
there's rico charges in the united
states you know that if you
that are that that came into existence
just for this you know just for this
kind of situation you know
um that you know it was more about
organized crime but that's what he was
that's what he was doing he was he was
a member of a criminal conspiracy
conspiracy an organized uh criminal
uh enterprise and he was a willing
he was a willing participant in in doing
those things and they have ways to to
to to prosecute someone who does exactly
that um
but you know what they that they said is
that you know they're they're looking
for him
and can you know because of the crimes
that that they know of and and then i
like i said that in the last one you
know they they did make that explicit
based on what she told him on the phone
and he understands that it's not it's
not up in the air
you know they're definitely chasing
after him
clive j thank you for the 10
wasn't that crispy esposito with the
ponytail putting the tie on the guy in
the courthouse makes sense she'd become
a public defender
and the timeline adds up yeah we we
touched on that earlier like i said i
looked i didn't see anything in the
credits or on imdb or anything like that
but
i like the idea i think it's a good idea
giant
thank you for the five dollars the
redemption episode i didn't realize i
needed after 6 12 i'm more okay now with
whatever gene decides though i'm still
hoping for his redemption
i agree
i agree absolutely
and uh pete i kind of uh was having so
much fun i lost track of time and i see
we're almost at the two hour mark so i
probably need to sign off here shortly
but then maybe we do one more question i
can go out on
all right yeah
sorry i didn't i didn't realize i didn't
realize we got to two hours already
either so i guess we were having fun
mm-hmm
yeah um
sorry i don't know i i i i guess for
this i think we've talked about it so
many times with the idea of redemption
um yeah i agree i'm i'm still hoping for
gene's redemption
yeah
i mean i think we're supposed to you
know it's not it's not wrong like i see
people
angry comments all the time like how
could you be thinking that you know
how could you're so dumb for for wanting
that it's like i i think pretty plainly
that's what the show wants us to to
think you know yeah it's pretty
unambiguous i i mean
like it doesn't mean that's what we're
gonna get it doesn't mean that's what
we're to get but that's what they're
trying to say they're saying this how
does a how does a good guy
become a bad guy and how do we feel
about that right yeah exactly we know
money was a good guy so we don't want
him to be that bad guy anymore right
excuse me
kunai panchal thank you for the a799
maybe gene calls the disappearer
the van arrives but the fbi are in it
maybe kim provided details when she came
to abq that could be an apt end
all right gil you have to get going so
what do you think about that
uh well we touched on this earlier
i guess this adds the wrinkle that kim's
in on it
um
i don't think it's impossible that kim
does something in the finale to further
squeeze gene because
if we if she feels like for her to get
full redemption she needs to completely
clear out everything she's lying about
and let everything out then the one
thing she still held on to is that she's
protecting
uh jimmy i've even seen some people
interpreted her crying as her having
decided i'm gonna go
um
i'm gonna go turn in saul essentially
um that's not the way i interpreted it
um yeah no
but i i don't think it's impossible that
she makes that decision in the final
episode
uh in terms of the van arriving and it
being a setup uh it does feel like
whatever happens in the next episode the
walls are closing in right now and i
think we're going to continue to see
them close in so that may include an
attempt to disappear and seeing that
that's no longer an option
but we also talked about the fact that
we want to see
redemption right so that means we want
to see gene make the choice to face up
to his actions
which would mean that the disappear is
available
uh but he makes a choice not to use it
uh yeah you know again it's possible
that the disappear is not available
and he still makes that choice but it
feels like for that choice to really be
meaningful it has to be made before
every other avenue has been taken away
if that's the only choice available it's
kind of less
interesting
but also
that wouldn't necessarily be wrong that
could be the thing they were deciding to
say about this character they could just
they could decide that he is
irredeemable this is a cautionary tale
you have watched somebody harden
themselves into a corrupted personality
and that's it you know he made these
mistakes hey don't make those mistakes
in your life
that could be the choice they make
yeah and
we know we were talking earlier about
we didn't particularly want to see her
help him in being her his lawyer i i
definitely think that that would
diminish his decision like you're saying
if if she made it for him by turning him
in you know what i mean like that that's
no redemption at all for him that's just
him getting caught right and being held
accountable
uh against his will so
yeah i think i think that
that that's about all i have to say on
that do you want to um
say anything before you uh
dip out
yeah i'll just say um thank you again
for having me on and this has been a
really fun way to celebrate the end of
this series
uh and i'll just say uh for for big
episodes of better call saul
um over on one take we like to do a sort
of watch party a pre-show so we'll
definitely be doing something like that
for the finale uh probably a few
episodes before the finale actually airs
so if you are like me and on monday
you're going to be distracted all day
just thinking hey the final episode of
better call saul is tonight then you can
join us in sitting there talking about
the show while we wait for it to air um
and then you guys actually had uh uh
bill oakley himself on one of those
shows too right yeah yeah that was one
of the uh best moments of my my youtube
career is uh we got peter deseth on who
plays bill oakley we did a sort of
trivia night for better call saul and we
figured we needed a good district
attorney to keep an eye on things and
make sure nobody cheats the little did i
know that by then he'd already become a
defense attorney so i kind of messed
that up but yeah but yeah he made an
appearance which was very cool
yeah
all right yeah i'll we'll do this at
least one more time next week so i'll
see you then and thanks again for coming
on
uh let's talk soon talk to you soon take
care everybody
all right db
db cooper thank you for the 4.99 what is
that a godfather reference when kim
leaves saul's office
the shot when kay leaves michael in his
office and they close the door behind
him
um
i didn't i didn't pick up on that myself
it's possible
i i thought what really stood out to me
about that was how
infuriating it is the way that he the
way that that works and and i thought a
lot back to
you know to the way chuck interacted
with jimmy the last time they saw each
other you know when he told him you
never really mattered to me
it never really mattered that much to me
or whatever however he said that um
and i just think you know the the thing
the focus there was kim trying to think
about what she might say and there
really not being anything that she could
say
deken
thank you for the 201 yen i think uh do
bcs more broken open credits mean
something
i think it's just the degradation the
degradation of the vhs is you know the
the degradation of the character um
the effect that him living that way has
on him as a as a human being and and and
the question that comes along with that
of hey is there is jimmy still inside
there somewhere can he come back out we
saw a little bit of that in the last
episode but it's not really clear how
it's going to play out
beyond that you know it's up it's open
for interpretation
jay castro thank you for the doll 199
gene hitting the piano note real loud
was reckless it was odd i mean i guess
he was testing the waters he's he's
expecting that the you know the guy
might be uh so out of it that he
wouldn't realize it but um i kind of
thought the same thing
not really necessary
a bunch of characters that i can't read
three dots
eight dots uh nine dots whatever it is
thank you for the
cancer guy equals james link and
yeah i saw that and this is uh i can't
remember the reference but this is
actually a reference to something else
um
i can't remember though sorry
that is his name and it's based on
a character or a person in real life
as well
uh sam jan thank you for the five
dollars so if jimmy copies or copes with
pain
by scheming and becoming soul
and chuck caused jimmy an immense amount
of pain in life
what do you all think are the
implications
um
i think you know it's interesting if you
go back and look
how he how this is
right from you know season one
where they decided to have his his old
friend marco back in uh
back home you know die
and and that's what
what you know his initial
foray and like where he walks away from
mesa verde and his original his initial
foray into going back into being
slipping jimmy you know this is pre-saw
obviously but
you know
it's interesting that that's his that
they laid out that that defense
mechanism early on and then they build
off that
and chuck
chuck was a little bit different i think
because they were brothers and and that
that had a different effect because he
he really cared about chuck even though
chuck
treated him terribly
what's interesting about him is that
after he died that's when we see you
know when jimmy can't handle how he hit
how how when jimmy can't handle that
after it happens that's when he starts
selling you know going out at night and
selling the burner phones and
started doing you know
it set him on the path of using the name
salt goodman
uh directly and so you know i think that
that's it's just been a progression of
like as more stuff gets piled on
he he just doubles down on on that that
mechanism that coping mechanism and you
know he never he never got to
even really have much time to get over
what happened with chuck even you know
like naturally even though he's not
doing any of the healthy stuff that
might
make that happen a little bit faster
because
you know lalo came into his life
and he you know did his trip through the
desert before like there's not that much
time that passed in between those two
events
kiko one thank you for the eight dollars
given oda kirk's recent ig activity can
we expect quentin tarantino as the
surprise co-director for the series
finale
uh thank you for putting the subtext
there in the parentheses afterwards
because i didn't understand the the
quentin tarantino connection
uh
i don't know what to say about that
except for man the internet just
absolutely blew up with that
in a 24-hour period it was it was
something to behold like i i just i was
sort of like am i missing something here
or is it just about him following that
account
and uh now it seems to mostly have
you know moved back into the background
jed gould thank you for the 199 kim's
decision avoidance is ptsd
i i think that could be part of it um
i i mean i think that she is
experiencing psd for for sure
just in the same way that jimmy is uh i
think that
part of what she's doing though is a
choice
but i could be wrong you know i i
definitely could be wrong
cokey thank you for the 4.99 what is the
one question you would like to have an
answer to in the series finale
uh
i mean
i would like to think of something a
little more exotic but i mean i really
just want to know
what
what's going on with jimmy how much
jimmy is inside there
and uh will it be able to come back out
will he be able to face all of this
stuff that he hasn't been able to that's
caused all these problems
yup yup yup yup yup i i interpreted it
as yep as we see on the screen right
here
i've i found it kind of interesting how
some people
i get the yup is is sort of a season
five reference to um
kevin wachtel's father and that great
scene
but i i thought the way that they were
saying um
saying it in this episode was why ep
rather than y up but thank you for the
two dollars blue
blue stomach um
i'm not sure what the general consensus
is on how to spell that i've seen both
in the comments in my last video though
tin omen thank you for the five just to
think this all started with chuck
getting jimmy out of jail in cicero
yeah i mean if you keep going back you
can think of a thing that happened
before that too
you know
uh so many things happen
in both of their lives and everybody
else's lives in there um
but
yeah i mean on some level you could say
it all started with a uh
chicago sunroof
uh abdul raham thank you for the five is
kim away is kim waited four years to get
divorced or am i missing something
i don't think the timeline is clear
there
um
emilio doesn't necessarily make it in
2008 because
um the way that jimmy says that you know
or not the way the way jesse brings that
up to the ball before is that he got him
off a couple of times
in the past it doesn't really say
exactly when that is so
i was talking to a few different people
kiwi was one of them yesterday we were
trying to to
think of a way to make it more
focus it into an actual year and i don't
i don't think it's possible from just
what we saw on screen
it's sometime like i said earlier it's
some time after they did the remodeling
so it's sometime after 2004 and sometime
before he worked with walter white which
is 2008 but you have a big you have a
big window there
um one of the things that he was saying
kiwi was saying that that that kind of
made sense was that he thought that
this interaction
um you know with the with the signing of
the papers is before what we saw in the
209 flash forward when we saw him waking
up and
um
you know
doing the whole routine so
beyond that i can't really say for sure
k foster thank you for the five dollars
in breaking bad two bodies are found
after the super light explo after the
super lab explodes
with kim's confession can they connect
the dots no the two bodies they found in
the super lab were the two guards that
were upstairs
uh whenever they when they burn it um so
we already know who those two people are
and
kim's confession she doesn't know where
the bodies are
buried no one you know no one told them
where they went so
nothing that she says could would really
put the police on to that other than
like
you know circumstantial stuff like she
went to
as i know it says in the paper and the
the things you can see like she talks
about how she went to gus springs house
and
things like that so i mean they might
search
i guess but why would they there's
nothing to tell them the bodies are
underneath the lab to answer your
question
nothing at all as far as i can tell
um
dapper dave 2021 thank you for the two
dollars new favorite word in the english
dictionary yep
it was fun it was fun how it popped up
in other parts of the episode too like
the scene that um
that's up on the screen right now but
you know it was it was definitely a
florida thing
but they they also
used it in a couple other
different situations in the
conversations to kind of echo what was
going on there
true underscore west thank you for the
499 jimmy's purgatory would be prison
helping his fellow prisoners and likely
former clients full of dead-end scams
for the rest of his life
yeah i mean this is a popular idea i
don't you know
i don't know um
i wouldn't need to see that i think we
already know enough about
jimmy mcgill slash saul goodman slash
gene takovic that if he if he does get
go to prison at the end i think we can
all kind of imagine what that might look
like
um
and some people would think that that's
a
a decent existence maybe better even
than um you know what he's experiencing
in omaha working at the um
cinnabon
i tend to think that prison is always
worse than not being in prison uh you
know but
you know i get that i get the idea of
what they're saying you know that he he
would he would probably be able to you
know
uh
make his way in that in that environment
better than some people based on his you
know skills and things
my echo my shadow and me thank you for
the 9.99 moment of silence for our last
days of anticipation for this great
story
a no a moment of appreciation you guys
courtney and kiwi for giving this
community a voice raised bus scene made
me cry um
it was a terribly
touching moment i i didn't get choked up
when i was watching it uh i i don't
think and i i am uh you know that does
happen to me
quite often when i'm watching tv um
this kind of hit different than just
that uh
there was a relief behind it
and um
and then and i was just so in awe of the
actual performance and the way they put
it together like i kind of lost a little
bit of the emotion because it was just
so absolutely impressive
but um i totally don't think you were
alone in in that i mean it was it was a
moving moving scene and um
you know thanks for the thanks for the
9.99 thanks for the moment of
appreciation
um
i'm glad that you're here i'm glad that
you're here
renny 10 renny 180 hd thank you for the
two does jean and marion episode end
parallel to hank and walt
um
i mean i'm not sure
it to me is it this is sort of
he's he's just on like i i kind of feel
like marion's story is over
in a way
like she served her purpose as far as
him being on the run
i don't see how
you really
how she would really play a major role
in anything going forward um so there's
so logistically it's a little bit
different but yeah i mean i see where
you're going where you're coming from
with that
uh emma thank you for the ten dollars i
wonder if we see a kim scene
how they'll make jeans ending satisfying
with how little time is left to end the
story
i think knowing that ed can't show up
makes gene getting caught very likely
yeah those are all good points um like
we've we've touched on
a bit already that
the ed thing
i mean it's definitely being teased in
the teaser but if if that if it gets to
the point where he's he's actively
thinking about that
the hope is that he'll change his mind
and he'll face it and he'll do what he
has to do in order to
kind of move past this place he's been
stuck in
as he just keeps you know throwing scams
on top of scams to to numb the pain um
i don't think that i'm not really
worried about
time though um
you know the
like i said a while ago there there's
only really the two questions
left now um
it's a really big story in a really big
world but they're
they've pretty efficiently
checked off all the boxes you know like
if people were kind of waiting around to
see if there was going to be more cartel
or more
you know
answers about breaking bad stuff i mean
i think they kind of
shut the door on that here like so it
it's really just um another hour or so
of
of seeing the resolution of of him being
on the run so i'm not too worried about
time um
but we'll see
ramsay bolton thank you for the five
euro do you think that they do you think
they find howard's body in the lab
because of kim's confession
just touched on this with another
question and my answer would be no i
don't really other than her saying that
she went to
gus's house and that mike you know
helped cover it up i don't really see
how that puts them on the lab and
um it's a cold case in a way too at this
point so
it just depends i guess but
i i don't i don't really see how that
would make the story
better um
but
we'll have to wait and see
brian hefferon thank you for the five
dollars any word on the length of the
finale is it any longer i believe so i i
can't i can't point you to a reference i
did see someone talking about the
runtime
and it was complicated because they show
you know the the the tv guide or
whatever that they use it it says how
long when the episode starts and when
when it ends so
that doesn't take into consideration um
the commercial breaks so there was a
whole thing of like this is how many
commercials are usually in an episode
and this is when it would usually end
and i believe it said that it was uh you
know going to be more than an hour but
um nothing like you know
one and a half or anything like that
just maybe just a little bit longer than
60 minutes if i remember correctly
and that's without the uh that's without
the commercial breaks and which the
usual episode is only in the 40
40 plus range as far as i remember
charlene she thank you for the ten
dollars what do you think is the
significance of next
episode's title stall gone
well
as is usually the case there's more than
one way to interpret the uh
the title waterworks i guess is our most
recent example it's where she works and
it's also her breakdown on the bus and
you know the the raining and and the
break bad timeline and there's
you know quite a few different ways you
could interpret it it's all gone i think
is you know
his cover story's gone gene takabic he
can't just
uh remain in
um
you know in uh omaha anymore i think
though
with the when you when saul gone you
know i think
i would like to think that that
that that method that way of dealing
with this trauma is gone and you know we
he can get that he can get back to being
jimmy
now that this uh you know now this life
is is is
been compromised or
however that plays out i don't know i'll
be interested just hear what other
people think about it but
saul goodman is kind of a funny way that
he made the name so so sol gone
for the ending seems pretty fitting
i made his army thank you for the 449
euro or a pound sorry in my opinion one
more mike saul scene where mike tells
jimmy that lalo is dead
is buried next to howard and is able to
get him found
also one more chuck scene the czech
flashback feels more
possible than any others now that we're
we're pretty
firmly focused on jimmy mcgill
um the mic thing telling him that lalo
is dead
is kind of in contrast to the fact that
he still doesn't really believe that and
that he mentioned that he still doesn't
really believe that
and you could say that it's just because
he's so scared of lalo that he doesn't
believe what mike tells him but um
that would kind of undermine the whole
idea of him telling him where howard was
buried and
i just don't see that it doesn't it
doesn't seem like something mike would
do i don't see the necessity of it
and it's not something he would do just
to make jimmy feel better
in my opinion
okay
youtuber
the youtuber thank you for the ten
dollars i can't help but be frustrated
why
gene didn't casually stroll out of the
house and into jeff's car
the cops wouldn't have been suspicious
why did jeff have to over complicate
things
i think because the they had no idea why
the police were sitting there you know
that that was the way i interpret it
when i was watching is
why are these guys sitting behind him
it's night time there's other places
they could have pulled up on the street
why did they pick there to
eat their food you know i think it's
just one of those things
it's easy to say that
uh from from where we're at watching but
you know when a cop car pulls up and
you're actually committing a crime in
gene's case
it's uh it's a little hard to think um
as cool and uh
rational as as you're talking about here
youtuber but i i kind of get what you're
saying i i just think that
it was hilarious the way that he dealt
with the situation
so i'm glad that happened and um
i think you know it's all coming from
the fact that he had no idea why they
were sitting behind him
okay dash dash thank you for the five
dollars okay i humbly battle out kim
time equals diamond time
just realized with therapists i have
black and white trauma from my youth at
my dad's corner store tv triggers it
thank you pp it's okay all right thanks
thanks double dash
and thanks for the laugh um
sk agar ball thank you for the two
dollars and you are in the yup
the yup uh camp not the yep the yup
thank you for that two dollars um
big ralph
thank you for the ten
kim can't go back to florida because
miracle
whip kim no longer exists
once she made the decision to admit what
happened she is no longer in that space
no more sprinklers no more puzzles
no more yep
that's certainly an interpretation
um
i'm not saying that that
is not possible
uh the i you know gill was kind of
talking in that in that vein too and
i think that there is the direct
implication that she's going she's
returned the
the rental car she's on the shuttle
she's going back to the airport to fly
away does something interrupt that you
know that's that's to be said but
i think at least at at least what they
showed us
was that she was
coming to albuquerque to do what she
could
and then she was gonna fly somewhere
else and i and i took that as flying
back to florida to pick back up with her
life and
she may be different
um
not being able to make decisions not
being able to have an opinion
all of that is could could be what's in
her future but i don't i don't know that
there was any implication that she was
actually
gonna drop all that and walk away from
it i mean she's been there for some time
she has an existence she does
participate in it
it's not like she's hiding you know
that's that's the part that's really
important i think is that
in a way she cho she she chooses that um
and
and it serves a purpose in that it it
keeps her from doing things that could
cause harm so it's complicated and i'm
not really sure where they're going to
go with it in the next episode but
i was definitely under the impression
that she's going back um she came to do
a thing and she did it and now
she's you know she'll go back in some
some
uh you know
some capacity even if she doesn't stay
to me the happiest ending for gene would
be similar to the ending of his
manipulation of irene
he public publicly admits all his crimes
committed in bcs in breaking bad and
then turns himself in thanks for the
comment yeah and i think this is a i
mean these are things that i've been
saying
my other guests have been saying over
the weeks i mean it is
it certainly seems like the most
satisfying way to go um
how they'll how they'll make that come
out
how that'll be because they you know
they do the inevitable quite often and
they still manage to keep it kind of
exciting kind of surprising kind of uh
you know not exactly what the way you
expected it to come out so
i i think there's a pretty good chance
that's where they're headed but i'm not
sure how they're going to get there
adh
adhd whiskey thank you for the 10
jean timeline is saul's dream from ed's
shop
he'll wreck his car in the dream and
it'll fade back to color walt wakes him
up while saul mutters the dust filter
line
dream stops gene from going
dream stops
gene from going to
nebraska
any kind of threw me off there i
didn't read that as nebraska at first um
i'm not sure if you're serious uh
i i i'm for one there's a couple things
that i really dislike in in in stories
and fake deaths and it was all a dream
are the things that that i have an
aversion to that um
to the point where i don't like to even
factor them into what's happening
sometimes with the fake deaths that
really screws me over because
it's such a repeated thing that they do
because of all the drama that's involved
in it but um
i feel safe in saying that this is not a
dream and uh
i'm hoping that you're sort of saying
this in a in a tongue-in-cheek way but
if you're not and it turns out to be
right
i'm not going to be happy
i could tell you it won't be a fun
stream the last one will be uh
you know that that would be the
there's always these threads of like
what could how what would ruin the
ending for you and and
if a significant portion of what we saw
turns out to be a dream that is
something that could ruin it for me
8 hn ic8 thank you for the 199 her
becoming a lawyer again could be to go
versus gene
i don't i don't see that i don't see the
setup being there
um
i think i saw
i think i saw love in her eyes still uh
even after the awful situation of what
happened
in uh
in his office in the black and white
theme uh she had a strong emotional
response to him
and and it's a really
is a really
uh interesting thing that happens right
before she hangs up
he he comes off he gets really he gets
really aggressive any any any and he
really kind of shows his ass and and
you know the the feds can't find me i'm
still out here going you know like just
terrible terrible
choices
all the way
all the way through the conversation and
then he he does come back to the softer
spot and he just says her name kim
and he's about to say something he's
about to go somewhere that that she's
not ready for you know and and she
senses it and that's where she finally
gets the
you know the impetus to uh hang up the
phone to tell him i'm glad you're alive
and not go any further and and it's
really interesting
and i don't know what it says about
where they go from here but none of it
tells me that that
she
you know she's gonna want to bring him
down you know um
i i
i could be wrong but i don't see it
going that way
duel the dual deer thank you for the two
dollars do you see saul having a happy
ending i mean it gets harder and harder
to imagine what that would even be let
alone
thinking it might happen i think
redemption i think
in short of redemption i think relief
is what i'd be hoping for
um
happy ending i mean you know there's no
i don't think there's a way where they
you know he him and kim come back
together
that's not even they they've even sort
of poisoned that there's a poison pill
in that in that they're
addicts and being together is terrible
uh for them and for people around them
so
i did a video months ago about what
would a happy ending even be and and i
and i don't really know and it doesn't
it hasn't gotten easier to try to figure
out what that might be
i think satisfying and cathartic and
things like that are
words we ought to think about more than
than happy
pmcc thank you for the five dollars
kim's affidavit links howard's death
with the cartel for law enforcement
does this trigger a closer look at the
laundromat
and uh this is another question about
this um
it's another one where
this is another situation like um
last week uh people kept saying what if
kim decided to turn herself in
because or or turn or you know tell the
truth about howard
and me and and courtney were we both
kind of kept uh
we both kept kind of discrediting that
because the timing didn't make sense why
six why would six years was that would
this happen you know and
that turned out we turned out to be
absolutely wrong about that and there
was a great explanation for why she did
what she did and that was because she
talked to jean
and you know
that was that was her catalyst and
so yeah i mean
i don't think that this is not something
that i worry about howard's body being
discovered i feel like it would feel
like a post script like it's not
necessary
howard had an ending
now his wife got you know the affidavit
and all of this um
feels like enough for me um
you know but
if they do something like they did with
this call
then okay
you know it's possible i i just the the
lab is just not
where my head is whenever i'm thinking
about jimmy being on the run and and and
everything that's going on like in in
the main story you know it feels kind of
side sidebar stuff
uh johann gorder thank you for the
sck-50 i'm not after
i'm not after bash any creator do you
share the opinion that things has become
less good without gilligan
as soon as he came back it's great again
um no i i don't agree um
i think uh seasons four and five were
excellent
um
i i and i think that
from the beginning he's he was never he
was the co-creator he was never the
showrunner
and he didn't have that final creative
veto except for maybe
through his personal relationship with
peter gould and and you know debts that
are owed back back and forth and all
that kind of stuff but
i think that when you when you when you
look at it in this this way i think you
kind of take away from from from peter
gould's and and everyone else's
contributions
and and just on the face i think i think
seasons
i mean i think he left part way through
season three so he was only really
involved in seasons one and two
and i wouldn't say that that season six
feels like some kind of triumphant
you know return to form
of of being like season one and season
two necessarily um
i think it's i think that
i think one of those things one of the
things there's a couple of things i
think that that really
uh that this that there was sort of some
privilege that this show had you know
like it got away with a lot of things
that other shows wouldn't for a couple
of reasons and and one of them was that
they just came off on on writing
one of the greatest tv shows of all time
and the other was is that they mostly
can keep all these people together i
mean of course
people you know
move on and new people take their place
but you know
they have this creative team that has
has
you know has just gotten better over
time because that you know because it's
all it's all in the same for 15 years
there's there's been this orbit that
that all of it's in so
i don't i don't i i can't i can't agree
with the premise that you're bringing up
there but um you know you're you're
you're welcome to have it
espeo thank you for the 9.99
okay all i got to say is kim
looking saucy asf in this episode also
why she's snitching
see a typical woman what was me after
she calls all this and then she tells
homeboy's wife
nah she's trippin
g kettle milk um
sounds like a bit of a joke i hope uh
other than that i don't know i mean
you're not asking a question really
you're you're telling me what you think
and uh
she's snitching on herself and it just
just just to say something uh
you know to add something to this is she
she's telling on herself
and she does
actively cover for saul by saying if
he's even alive so
i don't think it's i don't think it's a
classic case of her
being a snitch
jed ghoul thank you for the 1999 that's
very generous of course they can kill
saul but not in color
vincent peter have made a crucial point
that mentally
preparing yourself to kill is necessary
to kill
not the same but if you can do that the
next step is murder
yeah uh
vince and peter have made a crucial
point that mentally preparing yourself
to kill is necessary to kill
i mean i think so
but i you know i was also just thinking
about the beginning you know because of
emilio's return
walt never made himself
uh
you know he never made himself uh
prepared himself for that that was you
know that was a situation of
survival and and that's kind of how i
see
what what went down with marion um
i don't think that's a scenario he he
he rehearsed or he he really thought i
mean i think
i think when you do what they do at the
level they do and we saw this and what
happened with howard they figured that
they could uh you know control the
outcome
and and and
that works to a certain extent but
there's always unintended consequences
and um
i think if he was able to kill her it
would be more about the fact that he was
trying to
to survive and that's what we were
talking about i know you you you asked
this question a long time ago and it's
probably uh you know related to the
question or the conversation where you
have and then
but um
i mean on some level i agree
but um
i think that that i think the i think
that you know a lot of times people
a lot of times people don't make the the
conscious
a lot of what happens is not murder that
a lot of people die but it's not it's
not premeditated murder i guess is where
i'd leave that
slaggy star puff thank you for the 499.
after episodes 11 and 12 am i alone in
thinking 10 was meant to be the season
opener
if there had been no break better
foreshadowing momentum etc
um
you know i i was reading something
before and i can't remember exactly what
it was but they were talking about how
this show has always been a little bit
goofy in the way that they break up
um
the season breaks and stuff like that
10
i i think if you look at the structure
they they had to have 10 to to explain
who gene like to really
give us some time with gene because
we've only had we've only had really
small flash forward kind of cold open
things
but i think they needed to have that in
there before they could do what they did
in 11 and 12. and i don't know if that
lines up with what you're saying
you know as far as this but we said
earlier that it felt like it's almost
like a different season
and i think that that kind of is in the
same vein so i i hope that makes sense
um
it was necessary it didn't necess it
wasn't they had to show the flash
forward to close out 609
to underline the fact that that is how
he reacts to what happens and then they
did have to also
give us enough time with gene to kind of
understand where he's at so that when he
changes when that when that world gets
turned upside down it makes you know we
know where where his baseline is and
what's happening
grizzly industries thank you for the 499
do you think jeff will fold on gene when
he doesn't bail him out
no i don't think he's in all that much
trouble um it's mostly about
about
it's mostly about his um
you know the suspicion that he was
involved in the
the uh the break-in which he wasn't so
i i think that i think he's pretty solid
in there
uh marion will probably
intervene one way or the other before
too long anyways um
let's see
[Music]
gertz
medargas thank you for the two skirbs
sorry i didn't mean to to mispronounce
that
obviously
uh you know given name that you're using
there your your real name scarbs um
think about two dollars can i say that
blonde kim was way more hot
you can say that if you want to um
i won't make any comments on it but
but you can say that you're allowed
they put this out after the episode and
i thought the in color shots were pretty
interesting
thank you for that 199. that life alert
was a power move by marion
shaking my head yeah i i agree uh
the whole thing was was a was it was a
great setup i mean a lot of people had
had had picked up on this uh that she
conspicuously wore that around her neck
and it might come into play
and um
i was uh i i was glad to see that that
happened there and and it was such a it
was it was short but there was such a
shift back and forth
you know her saying hey this is i
trusted you
you know and
him being on the verge of just tearing
it off of her neck and just being like
look you can't do anything old woman
this is the way things are gonna play
out because he could if he wanted to do
that
so yeah it was uh
it was a it was a nice prop to to really
to really add some uh
to add to that scene
dilo thank you for the two dollars gill
and pete are awesome together great
combo glad you like it uh
thanks for for the for that and thanks
for
saying that
i was telling gail
you know last week i did this one maybe
like two hours of sleep
i was telling him before and i got so
many awful comments about how terrible i
am and and
and uh
it was
it was it was it was a little depressing
i mean i i got a lot of good ones too
but you know i i've had already felt
kind of bad about being spaced out
because i didn't sleep and then
having so many people
pile on and tell me that all my
uh you know all my worst fears were true
it it's nice to
see the opposite sometimes so thank you
for that hakeem sif thank you for the
two dollars why did saul refrain from
stopping marion
that is the question isn't it hakeem uh
we don't know exactly but the the
implication is that
the guy that we know that wasn't quite
as bad as the guy that he is right now
came back out and was it because of who
she is or was it because of of what
something that happened before there's
there's certainly
a lot of different ideas about that
floating around but we don't really know
um
i think you know the the big takeaway is
that there is something there is a
chance that he could turn around you
know i mean
that's what we're supposed to take away
from that is that it's it's not as it's
not as bleak as it's been over the last
two episodes
stringfellow hawk thank you for the 505.
i feel the series ends with kim and saul
jimmy talking
in jail through the glass with one or
both of them hanging up the phone the
end
could be
we we've talked about it several times
already i mean the
prison could be in the future form
that's definitely
uh you know within the realm of
possibilities
the glass booth you know it's a it's a
it's a common it's common prop in that
situation so it's not a terrible idea
salte thank you for the five dollars a
scenario for the last episode is that
oakley represents jean in court loses
and while in jail
saul slips one last time and cracks his
head open
okay
that is a scenario you're correct and um
i i can follow everything you're saying
there
not sure if it'll happen or not but
thanks for
thanks for letting me know about it
jose haley thank you for the 199 bet
jimmy and kim don't meet in prison ever
okay
i don't know if that's a direct rebuttal
to the last one but it works that way uh
so just think of everything i said to
that poster
and reverse it
oscar alvarez thank you for the 499 kim
not being prosecuted is because saul is
missing
that is not completely true anymore they
will see each other in court
well i mean saul is the only person that
could
be a witness um but
that's not to say that they would
absolutely
go forward if he was around i mean we'll
see
um
but yeah i mean i think i've said it
several times already i i don't i don't
like the idea of ending on a on a court
case but
if anyone can do it it would be these
writers so we'll see
frankie dima thank you for the 999 not
sure if you guys already touched on this
but i think the part where kim gets the
parking pass from the automated machine
is so subtly powerful
it really shows how far they've come in
the timeline yeah i said the same thing
in my video um
you know it it's it's kind of on the
nose in a way but it's perfect you know
it's one of those situations where you
can do that
because the the the revelation that the
revelation carries so much information
you know you can look backwards or
forwards and and you know it tells you
so much about
the place and you know one of those
things is
this this universe exists inside
albuquerque you know it's a big part of
of the story
it's kind of in the background because
you know it's a character-based drama
and we're we're always watching what
they're doing and everything else but
but yeah i think i liked it i like the
homage and i like the idea that you know
it's like a ghost town in a way for all
the characters we know and cared about
that inhabited that but it keeps going
you know it keeps going on
abdul raha rahman thank you for the five
which spin-off will interest next i
think it's enough but love to hear your
thoughts yeah i think it's enough
um i was i was over on uh
watching
vince and peter on inside the gilliverse
and i was surprised that peter peter
mentioned the gus spent off because he
was saying that we won't find out
anything else about you know spoiler i
guess um
you know that that they won't be
touching on what happened in chile for
gus and he said
we have to leave it in case we do the
the spinoff
um but i i did read something
yesterday about vince saying you know he
he's he's ready to move on but you never
know they might come back if he fails
and everything else he does i think is
the way that he puts it then
there's a good chance that they might
come back into this universe because
there always will be interest in them
doing that um
i i i
i you know i like it i i enjoy it i
wouldn't be
upset to see more
but um i'm i'm really kind of interested
to see what they do outside of it too
you know
alibaba thank you for the 4.99 do you
think
lalok
do you think lalo will kill saul maybe
it will be revealed it was actually
chuck that was buried underneath the lab
and ernie married paige novick
absolutely possible why not
um
i feel like you asked the same question
before and i had the same
i don't know how to react to this action
but
uh it might just be that we're getting
close to the three hour mark and my
brain is starting to dissolve
jed gould thank you for the 9.99 vince
and peter have made a unique point if
you are visualizing a murder
it's only a matter of will to kill
you guys don't want to mention that it
can still happen to saul
i don't think it's beyond him um and and
now we're i'm
i'm sorry that this is uh
you know like an hour and 15 minutes
after you ask the question that we
finally get around to them and that's
how it works um
because i because i can't really
pinpoint what we were talking about at
the time
where you where you gave these two um
to comments but i mean i i don't think
that he's been portrayed as a killer but
of course that could change
so i hope that i hope that works
scott alderman thank you for the two
dollars i thought jeff panicked when he
crashed into the cab
i i wasn't 100 sure it seems like
listening to what they are saying is
that it was a diversion i was kind of on
the fence when i watched the first time
too so i know what you're saying scott
um
i was like did that did he did he freak
out and he just did that or is this
actually him
you know an audible on his part uh you
know i wasn't really 100 sure but i do
think from listening to what they said
on the insider podcast and stuff like
that that it was he he did do it on
purpose
alex plaza thank you for the clp 5000 a
lot of people talked about jimmy
slipping
a bq word to marian at the phone
but she was already getting it
given she said she had to talk long
distance with people to help jeff
probably talk to jimmy as saul
i didn't pick up on that indication
i thought he made several
mistakes
you know first he forgot about nippy
then he said he was never in albuquerque
then he came back around
i thought that the way that it played
out i mean i really liked the idea
because i had a hard time understanding
how she would come across any
information that would be helpful to
to actually you know
give up his imp you know who he was so i
really like the idea that albuquerque
con man
in ash jeeves uh which is a throwback
all of its own sgs but um
i and i guess i was a little bit low i
was a little bit behind the curve
because i went curve i went and i looked
i put those words into google
and people had already figured out that
they would
put that commercial on youtube and in
the time between the episode and when i
tried it so that those were the top
results but um
i mean it's possible she'd talk to jimmy
assault i don't know how you know i
don't know how that really
would change things at this point it's
just sort of one of those things that if
you think that's the case then
you can and if not
it still makes sense for her to um to
get to the to their how they showed us
you know how how they laid out
more directly in the in the actual
episodes
are we going to get an explanation on
the diamonds in the band-aid box do we
need one or is it just the easiest way
for him to store hide his wealth
i don't think we need one
um
i'd be okay if they gave us one
i think it's one of the many different
ways i think in his in his conversation
with uh
francesca it's it shows that he was
diversified you know besides just
putting some in the wall and putting
some up in the drop ceiling he was he
was throwing his money around in
different ways to hide it
he knew that things might eventually
come back around on him so
i think this is just one of the many
ways
we'll see
yep thank you maybe not banksy for the
five dollars
uh
yep
david hatfield thank you for the 846
other than a kim prequel what characters
or story line do you see as a logical
progression in the breaking bad universe
as a special or series
i i don't know i mean there's so many
different side all the side characters
are pretty fascinating so you could go
in a lot of different directions with
those as main characters i think the the
general consensus is kim or or um
uh
gus
because he has a long back story that we
don't know all the details about but um
beyond that i don't know like i said i
think i think side characters would be
interesting but
we don't
there's too many of them to list off all
at once here
sue kron miller thank you for the five
dollars who would saul see in prison in
this timeline
tuka salamanca who else well tuko will
be out by breaking bad
so
and then he'll be dead
so
a lot of them are all dead i mean i i
don't know no one comes to the top top
of my head like if he went in as jean
i don't know i don't know what that
actually opens up as far as that's
concerned nothing as far as i can tell
amanda ruiz 619 thank you for the two
dollars how much sign pup pa pay uh
signed pap po
how much
sandpiper money did saul get he got
million
1.7 million i think is what they thought
it was at the end
it may have been more it may have been
more than 2 million by the end but um
i'm not sure
they did reference in this episode and
the fact that kim didn't want her part
of it so
i don't know how that changes things but
it was pretty obvious he got it with it
with the mansion but now we know for
sure
esteban garcia thank you for the 4.99
what predictions do you have about
walt's appearance
if saul goes to trial will anna gunn
testify
she could if that was the case
it doesn't seem absolutely necessary but
she knew him she knew what he did she
was part of that she made her deal based
on the lottery ticket of being able to
give up hank's location
hank ngomi's location to the ea so
i i you know i've gone over this a
million times i don't really have a
great prediction
it just has to be about what saul is
thinking and what how he reacts to his
situation at the end more than about
walt or filling in the blanks as far as
as breaking bad as far as i'm concerned
maybe something around
the situation with brock if if if you
had to pick one but there's a lot of
different ways they could go with it
silver scale thank you for the five
dollars well gene ex will gene escape
with a pickup from that one guy who
helped him hide
that guy he called for extraction at the
start of the season
that guy i believe you're referring to
is ed to disappear
there's a hint that he might
try to do that in the teaser that came
in the mid-credits but i'm not sure
the actor who played ed is
passed away after they made el camino so
he they couldn't actually physically
bring him back
um but i think you know the idea of what
we were talking about what gil and i
were talking about earlier we don't want
to see him doing that
we don't want to
we would rather him
make the decision not to use that option
if we're given the opportunity
thank you for the sar 25 do you think
it's fair for jimmy to get killed jailed
while jesse who killed someone got a
happy ending
no i mean
i don't expect the show to uh take
things like that into consideration fair
life isn't fair i mean that's not just
that's not really how things work so
i i i wouldn't
i wouldn't take what what he got
into my
you know into my my
uh thinking about what jimmy should or
shouldn't get you know that let's i i
would i would hope that they would think
about
you know how try to make them feel like
real characters in the real world and
how things work there
and not you know
not sort of subscribe to a
you know well if this happens here then
that has to happen across the board for
everybody else and you know it's they
have a lot more freedom than that so i
hope they would exercise it
trader chris thank you for the 4.99 can
you read my 10 super chat about how saul
goodman became a person of interest when
everyone who knows is dead
why did he run in the first place i i do
think i read this now and uh you know i
apologize that it takes time to get to
them i like to
uh you know
let them i like to answer all the
questions but i also like to let them
[Music]
open things up for a conversation
between me and my guests so you know it
takes a little bit of time i do get to
all of them i will stay here
and answer them all before i cut out uh
even after we're crossing this um
three hour threshold here
but yeah i i do believe i answered it at
this point and i'll just say uh sorry
for
the wait but i hope it was worth it
dan new york or dan ny i guess thank you
for the 199 kim and jimmy make peace
before both go to jail
could be the case
i don't really want to see kim go to
jail
uh
but
i guess
it's possible
i don't i think it would be be kind of
kind of a bad ending
but you
know
if there was a reason then i guess then
they can do that
xyos212
thank you for the five dollars burnett
and jeff field jammed in isolated at the
end of the series similar to the nazis
in breaking bad
i would have preferred established
characters in the end well they're not
many established characters still alive
though so
i'm not sure who you wanted to step up
like you wanted to be all about kubi at
the end or uh
who's another character skyler it could
have been about skyler white
um
i'm not sure
i mean i'm
there's more than that but i mean
you know
i feel like whenever people have this
idea
it's more about they want to spend more
time not in where we're at in gene's
timeline but but maybe more back around
like the cartel and
those people are all dead so i'm not
sure if that's what you meant or not
but i think that burnett and jeff worked
for me so
uh
i'm not i'm not coming from the same
place at least you know
it's a fair it's a fair uh
criticism
i mean a lot of people felt the same way
about
the nazis like you bring up but um
i mean i wasn't a big fan of that but it
it worked and for what for what it did
nick lemke thank you for the 4.99 mike
mike back next week his finale was
perfect in 609 but then brought him back
in 611 which seemed kind of
inconsequential
not sure there's time though
i thought that he i thought he worked i
thought the way they brought him back
kind of made the whole thing with
bringing
walt and jesse back in that timeline
work a little better
i thought those scenes were
complementary so i didn't really have a
problem with it
but um
the only the only reason why that i i
feel like it's necessary to go back to
that timeline now is because i know that
there's supposed to be another walt uh
appearance
so
he could be connected to that but other
than that i would feel fine if we don't
see him again
but happy to see him if he does show up
and there's a good reason for it oops
sorry about that alex dyer thank you for
the five do you think it's possible saul
takes his own life essentially going out
on his own terms
it's it's a thing that that
um
that really seems
anti-it doesn't really seem to go along
with what the character is um
it's something they used before
uh
with his brother
um i mean obviously with nacho and some
other characters too but i mean with his
brother i i kind of don't like it for
that reason but that's just a personal
you know like there it doesn't mean it
can't happen that's just a personal um
aversion that i have
trans trem thank you for the five
dollars what are the odds the vacuum
cleaner guy placed saul in hiding in
florida working at palm creek i think
that the actual odds of that are
are pretty low
um
pretty low indeed could he could he uh
could he orchestrate that maybe but it
doesn't sound like a very satisfying
ending um doesn't sound like he'd be
you know dealing with what he's been
burying all this time if he if he would
orchestrate that scj thank you for the
499 not sure if this has been asked do
you expect the full theme song of bcs to
play in the finale and or a third
something stupid montage
i feel like if there would have been a
third something stupid montage that
would have happened in this episode i
think they passed up on the opportunity
for that
i mean i guess they could show
gene
running in the moments after he left
marion's
place while kim just goes back to her
regular day at work it would be a little
bit weird but
you could maybe make that work
i don't really have any investment in
them playing the full theme song of bcs
heard it i understand that it's i mean
it's good i like the song
i don't really know what it adds to the
actual
story
or how that you know how that's other
anything other than
you know some if we if you know about it
and you heard it and you like it then
you get to hear it other than that i
don't know what it would really add to
the story
alex middleton thank you for the 9.99 on
talking saul last night bob odenkirk
described the last episode in three
words when asked
one hard truth
how do you interpret this clue i didn't
get to see it i didn't hear that until
right this minute
um
my my knee-jerk reaction is that
he's responsible
he didn't
yeah i i don't know
one hard truth
the word one that qualifier of one there
makes it
makes it pretty difficult
uh to i mean you pretty much have to
commit to what that one thing might be
and um
timmy's such a complicated character
that's not easy to do
i i don't know uh if something comes up
by the time i get to the end of these
i'll i'll circle back around to it but
right now nothing jumps right in nothing
comes straight to mind
thanks for bringing it up though because
like i don't get to see that here so um
i'm i'm glad to to know that that's out
there
blk underscore regina underscored george
thank you for the 4.99 love and
appreciate the content love when
howard's wife asked kim what was it all
for
do you think kim shared an elaborate
plan for with her
i
this is a choice i i wanted to bring
that up earlier uh so we could discuss
because
it's an interesting choice i think on
the one hand we know what kim would say
um
she can't really she can't really give
her a good answer
nothing more than was already in what
what she said like i've gone back and
looked at what what's on the paper
and it lays it out pretty evenly
um so it's interesting i i don't have a
great answer i i don't think she i think
that when she asked her why she's doing
this
i i think that that the
the thing that she should say is because
it's the right thing to do and she
regrets what happened
before the way that she handled it
before
specifically you know when you say do
you think kim shared an elaborate plan
with her
and i i don't i don't think so that
wasn't my my my guess my my guess was is
that you know she was there that she
kind of held it together and then we see
her breakdown later is an indication
that
she was accomplishing what she came what
she came there to accomplish so i i
expected whatever she told her
didn't derail anything it was it was
it was the best that she thought she
could
and there was some satisfaction in that
and then you know then she then she
really
experiences the emotion that she's been
held down as a result later you know
that as a result of that later
brendan g thank you for the a5
dollars big fan from australia is there
any chance jimmy gives the diamonds to
mike's family somehow
i think uh
just as an idea there was that you know
that you could have thought that but i i
don't see how we get there after the end
of 6 12. you know like i don't really
he's on the run he's fighting for
survival i don't know how you get to the
point where all of that has been put
aside and he has a chance then to
re find out where mike's family's at and
give them that
fred miglerini thank you for the 4.99
instead of gene transitioning to color
how about they show saul leaving the
vacuum store
and try and transition to black and
white
yeah i mean that would fit in with the
other
you know that was my initial idea of
what i thought um
where they thought they might show walt
uh
gil brought this up earlier and
if they showed him in the thing so i
guess they could do that they could show
that color turning to black and white on
his way out
it might be fitting for people who never
saw breaking bad to kind of see
how that makes sense um
but
um other than that i don't know what to
say it's a good idea fred but i'm not
sure if we'll see it
steve bob jd thank you for the 4.99 why
do you think that gene didn't kill mary
and was killing someone too much for him
did he care about marion or something
else
we touched on this a few times already i
don't know that we know for sure
i think i think the actual answer is
because she said
i trusted you
and that and that pushed a button inside
him um
how you interpret that how you interpret
that is is
is up to you and we'll probably find out
a little bit more in the next episode
but i think that that was the actual
thing
the words that she chose and and her
being who she was her being an elderly
woman that trusted him
him seeing
the dirtiness that's involved with that
you know on some level on how how
how he thought he had under control he
thought that
he wasn't harming anyone but himself and
blah blah you know just sort of it's
just all sort of fits into the addiction
uh
thing and um
i think that has a lot to do with it
brandon goldberg thank you for the 4.99
what do you think the significance of
the diamonds he has is
i think it's another
way they do you know there may be an
there may be a specific
significance on how he got them but i
think it's just another
thing in in the you know and the
portfolio of different tools that he put
together to hide his wealth that you
know he had
i don't have a better idea for that um
it's just sort of all i got there he is
one of the one of the many different
ways that he that he hid his money
and
it happens to be convenient because you
can move around pretty easy with that
and he had to run away from albuquerque
adhd
whiskey thank you for the five dollars
black and white dreams often symbolize a
sense of loss therefore if you keep
dreaming in black and white
you feel saddened by losing friendship
or love
okay that's not something i've ever
heard before i've never
done a lot of uh investigation on on the
symbolism of dreams but it sounds solid
um
i'm not one that has a lot of dreams so
i i'm not great for
uh doing that like i couldn't tell you
if my the last few the few dreams that i
remember
recently i can't remember if they were
black and white or color or much other
detail
um i don't have a lot of it but a lot of
vivid dreams joe carter thank you for
the fi uh the 15 australian
i appreciate that
nothing to go along with it so i'll just
say thanks
peppa
thank you for the nok22
nok22 happy ending with saul moving to
belize
happy for who peppa happy for who
how would that be a happy ending
from what perspective would that be
oh man i'm sorry
ratna parky
thank you for the 200
i know this is yellow so i know it's
it's not
not the minimum uh so thank you for that
bb ending hat
bb ending had definite conclusions for
to who for two who hank jesse the family
and walt
here the focus will be on concluding
storylines or will it be open ending
open ended leading to multiple
interpretations
i lean towards open ending open-ended um
because i think it makes more sense for
where this character is i mean
if he dies then okay then that's not
not very open-ended um
but other than that i i think
i think that because we've known him for
so long and we've seen
that all these different parts of his
life interact and they put it all
together i like in it i like open-ended
better
we have a lot of definite conclusions
like we know what happened to howard we
know what happened to nacho we know what
happened to lalo gus mike and all these
different people so
yeah we'll see but i i i lean towards
the
to him you know him him reckoning with
what he hasn't been able to to reckon
with and hopefully there's some sort of
redemption in that
and then we can decide
we can make up what comes after in our
own minds lunar orbit thank you for the
five dollars canadian do you think jeff
crashed the cab on purpose to distract
the police so gene could escape or was
it pure nerves
yeah i mentioned this earlier i
my initial take while watching it was i
don't know i don't know if that was
supposed to be
he just freaked out because of the
pressure it didn't really they didn't
really set it up that great if that was
the case but
it was such a weird choice of thing to
do
that um you know
i thought that was possible but i do
believe after listening to the insider
podcast and and other things that they
they intended it for him to be
he did that you know as a describe he he
did that on purpose as a distraction so
that gene can make it outside of the
house
alexander kepchar thank you for the 499
crazy thought jimmy ends up in court
stripped of any all wealth so needs
public defender appointed
fitting punishment is
lip
life in prison but chris espizito is the
public defender
could be
um
that would tie together those things
that you bring up there uh
like i've said a few times already in
this stream it's not not the the outcome
i'm hoping for but if they you know if
anybody can do it they could do that and
i'll
i'll i'll judge it on it's on its you
know how it works in the moment rather
than
just not being the thing i want want to
happen
you know happening
johan gamble putty thank you for the 499
flashback young jimmy gets caught taking
money from the till by his mom
who looks him in the eye and says i
trusted you
yeah i mean there could be the literal
thing there
it's funny because
this this opens up a whole different can
of worms that i used to think about a
lot that i don't really expect to get
much closure on like i always wondered
if
if um
if chuck's idea about this was correct
you know i always wondered if if
that's sort of his original sin
as far as chuck's concern was you know
stealing that money
and um
there i remember at the time there were
some there was some
you know there was some idea that maybe
his mom was bad at the books or she she
was cooking the books and
the way that that played out was that
chuck was mistaken in thinking that you
know it was jimmy stealing all along i
mean we saw jimmy steele a little bit um
but you know i always wondered if that
was the case you know that he really
stole as much as he thought because
that's a lot of money for a little kid
especially at that time i hadn't ever
really thought about it on this level of
like
maybe he maybe marion makes him think
about his mother
it would feel a little bit left
it would feel a little bit out of left
field but we'll see you know what i mean
like
there there is stuff to pull on there
you know there there's his you know his
mother's dying
and the effect that had on chuck and all
that other stuff so i could see where
you're coming from i just it's not
something that occurred to me until
right this moment
mr dude 79 thank you for the 199. i fear
for jeans saul's jimmy's life
well i i i hear you um
i don't think he'll die but it's as we
mentioned a few times already in this
it's definitely possible so i hear what
you're saying
my echo my shadow and me
thank you for the 199 gene's not the
kind of girl to give up like that
yeah i didn't even get to mention this
when i was doing the recap that that
scene because there's so much other
stuff going on right there
it's an underrated it's an underrated
choice to have him do that it is and
what what i what i really liked about
the scene and what sticks with me is
that is that's the kind of song that
even if you don't know the words like
jimmy definitely doesn't know anything
but the uh
you know they made it clear that he only
knows the chorus
it that's a that's a song that you sing
along with
when the chorus comes on because just
it's just that kind of song you know
what i mean so i thought that was a
pretty funny
little addition to kind of you know
kind of give us a little bit lighten
things up a little bit before they go
all the way dark in that next scene
ebert's two dollars i think a lalo
prequel spin-off would be great i would
have agreed with you before
but ever since we got to the end of the
lalo's story i i don't really find
myself
longing for more of it um
i don't know if that makes sense but
fascinating character great character
i'm not saying that i that the way the
story his story ended kind of took away
from that you know i think he was a good
character i would like to i would watch
a show about them if they made it for
sure
i just i don't know the whenever his
story came to a conclusion i just didn't
find myself wanting more
i just felt like
it you know it just felt good the way
that where it ended how it ended
we knew it was inevitable and uh so i
was happy that they could at least make
it
an exciting
you know exciting thing whenever they
you know we knew almost exactly how it
was going to happen too
so i guess it just didn't make me think
oh okay now i want to learn so much more
about this guy although it would be fun
to watch
raphael baker thank you for the 799
australian
could
could see
walt give some advice
when they were in ed's basement together
yes
this has come up a couple of times since
you asked the question so i hope you
were around to hear that but
i do think that that's a thing that was
actually before
before i expected to see those two
characters get tires together that was
my initial thought
was that they could give us a little
more in that and then whenever i heard
it was both of them
but before the time whenever i found out
that they had
scenes together and scenes apart
you know i i kind of kind of lost
interest but it's definitely still one
of the better ideas out there i think
david l thank you for the 4.99 thoughts
on how the bets black book will come
into play
i think it already did i i think that
you know their little talk him mike's
talk
about the second story man and all that
i thought that referred back to it i
don't think i'm not expecting to see
more about the black book
i think they set it up that that
caldera was going to sell it
they set up that it was going to be in
jimmy's
uh mansion he was gonna get it
eventually
i i don't know that they're gonna
connect dots on on how he you know he
paid him for that
i think it makes sense for him to go and
get it once he once he
decides after kim leaves
and he decides that he wants to to
you know throw himself more into the to
the criminal lifestyle
under boss films thank you for the 199
clearly jeff was rewritten for pat
writers lying okay
i take them at their word but you can
call them liars if you want to
and it looks like we made it to the end
of the rainbow
oh james eagan
thank you for the 799 australian
would love to see a fan edit of all the
genes and episodes into one movie i mean
there's one out there that has all the
uh all the cold opens
stitched together on youtube that you
can find
but yeah it would be cool to to um
see it after you know we get the
conclusion at the end
and guys i want to thank you all for
showing up it's been three and a half
hours and i'm way past my limit sorry
for uh kind of trailing off a little bit
um
but i am gonna have to get out of here
before i
space out completely
so thanks for coming out i will try to
do one on saturday because it is the
last episode
i want to
uh
i want to do that i'm going to be pretty
busy but i'll try to make it happen if
not we'll definitely be back here next
tuesday
and we'll um
you know be talking about the finale
i can't wait for that and uh thank you
for coming out and oh
what right in there at the buzzer okay
samson hj thank you for the 200. why
should everyone who breaks bad end up
losing everything
what is the storyteller really trying to
tell to all of us who are trying to set
things right
i don't think it i don't think that they
have to lose everything i think actually
if you really look at it
walt and jesse got off
kind of easy you know that
walt got to make a lot of things right
before he died and
in reality he was dying anyways because
of cancer so all of that could have
never happened and he could have just
died
or he could have not you know he
couldn't i i don't think it's it's it's
it's too gloomy you know
um
i don't think it's as dark as as
as it as it's as it sounds um
i think the only thing the storytellers
are trying to tell us is that you know
life life works in the way that when you
make you make decisions and those
decisions have consequences
because we're you know it's dramatic and
as a narrative for television in a
dramatic tv series of course they're
going to lean towards those consequences
being you know
substantial and uh and exciting to watch
but um
you know i think if you if you sort of
if you sort of
zoom out a little bit
what's interesting is is is just how
people
how people make decisions and how people
react to things that happen to them
and how those decisions lead them them
different places and um you know i don't
think it's i think there's a little bit
of of of uh
you know morality that fits into that
but i don't think it's overly
uh moral in its message
it's just sort of like you know
we're watching this happen we're
watching it together
and we can relate because we're all
humans and we see humanity in
what they do
so all right guys thanks for watching i
will talk to you